e
e e
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs uh we're
going to be having a a number of things
today a work session um public hearings
and an executive session later this
afternoon but before we get into any of
that please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you
everyone okay uh we're going to start
our day with a work session uh as
previously scheduled on Senate Bill
409 and uh representative Shapiro has
offered us an amendment number
1529h and representative Shapiro would
you like to speak to this
amendment thank you Mr chair um this
amendment 1529h which I have yet to read
I just picked it up um simply adds an
appropriation to the original bill for
$1 million which was the estimated
amount for the state
share of um increased Medicaid re
reimbursements
um in addition it says that the
appropriation will not take effect
until um the application for State
Medicaid plan amendment is accepted by
CMS it does not address any of the other
questions that were brought up when we
originally discussed this bill about the
particular categories that would um
qualify servic is for reimbursement and
I assume that those will be discussed
here
today okay yeah representative
Weber and I thought of putting in an
amendment that addresses items a through
F on lines 12 through 22 but I really
thought that it would be better for us
to discuss as a committee and see what
what direction the committee wanted to
go in before doing that but I would like
to uh address that at the appropriate
time and if the appropriate time is now
I'll go ahead but if not sure I've got
other things why not so the concern that
I have in the drafting
are
um
the now let me just see if there's a
change there I do remember during the
hearing you okay um there is a slight
change in the drafting with
representative Shapiro's Amendment
because the bill as it came to us said
providers shall be eligible for Medicaid
reimbursement under this paragraph only
when all the following requirements are
met and in the amendment it says
providers shall be eligible for Medicaid
reimbursement under this paragraph when
each of the following requirements are
met and I think that the that's really
just a different way of saying the same
thing um the so I was wondering if we
could go
through one by one would this be
appropriate and I could ask poll the
committee members who are here on what
what they think ought to be done with
each one because it seems to me
something like B the patient consents to
evaluation and treatment is an absolute
requirement um if the patient doesn't we
shouldn't be I mean they shouldn't be
reading but that's a whole another thing
uh so that that one would be okay the
first one which is a is the response
originated through a 911 call and uh my
understanding is that there are other
ways of having the call originate other
than through
911 and I don't see why we would have
that limitation it didn't occur it was
not in the companion build that we had
from from the the house so I would love
to strike that one
entirely and this is just personal
preference on my account um number two
the patient consents to evaluation and
treatment and that has to be
mandatory um and then C D E and F seem
to be to be one of those has to be
present but not all of them necessarily
have to be present but I'm more than
willing if if other people have thoughts
on how that ought to go because and and
the um bit about online 17 this shall
include when resuscitation efforts are
terminated I think that ought to be in a
whole separate category because I don't
think it ought to be attached to one or
another but I do think yes reimbursement
ought to happen if if resuscitation is
unsuccessful okay any uh any other
thoughts representative
McCay your microphone isn't
on under for line 14 the patient
consents to evaluation and
treatment many patients are
unable to make that uh decision I I
don't like going back to my own
experience but I was in conquet hospital
for 3 days and don't even remember being
there never mind making any
agreements uh so that uh I don't know
what you do instead of that whether that
is a family member consents to evaluate
but there are many people who are
incapable of making that
decision Mr representative Weber this
bill does not cover that situation that
situation when somebody is
unresponsive is completely different
because if somebody is
unresponsive they are going to be
transported um it's only when they can
knowingly
um consent to treatment and knowingly
say I do not want to be transported so
either first of all they have to
have
capacity to consent to evaluation and
treatment and they have to have the
capacity to either agree there's no need
for
transportation actively refuse
transportation
um deem that they're stable for referral
to The Physician or um and and I think
that E and F actually have to go
together the patient is stable for
referral to the patient's physician and
has the ability including mental
capacity and transportation resources to
obtain that assistance so I think that
those two actually go together but if a
patient is nonresponsive or simply does
not have the capacity to consent this
this bill doesn't cover that situation
and nothing would change for those
patients
okay representative McKay
yep representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair first of all
I don't know how all got changed to each
so that wasn't requested but somebody
took that on to do that on their own um
I would I I essentially agree with
representative Weber's suggestion about
um making it one of the um C through f
um it does seem to me that in D the
patient does not request and actively
refuses um that it maybe it should say
the patient does not request or actively
refuses
yep I'm sorry which line was that
representative in the amendment it's
line
18 the patient does not actively request
and strike out and and put in
or is my suggestion okay does not
request or actively refuses
y
okay and so if I may the my suggestion
would be that after that change which I
agree with on D we would take E and F
and put them together so it would read
something in the nature of the patient
is stable for referral to the patient's
physician other community resources and
I'm going to put the deceased bit in
with the bit about resusitation efforts
being terminated in
17 um and so e would be the patient is
stable for referral to The Physician
other community resources and the
patient has the ability including mental
capacity and transportation resources to
obtain assistance and medically
medically indicated followup so that it
is clear that they are capable of
seeking the treatment they need
themselves um and I I would put those
two together and then I would put uh
resuscitation efforts are terminated or
is
deceased I I would have to sit quietly
and find a sentence that works for that
but my point would be to to make that a
separate category so for
clarity and which which line is that
um in line 17 it says this shall include
when resuscitation efforts are
terminated and in line 21 it says or is
deceased so I think those could be one
category yes it's clear that if your
resuscitation attempts are uh
ineffective
yes you still get
reimbursed okay anyone
else represented mlan I have some
questions and I had to work last week so
I missed this and so I apologize um but
just from for my clarification since
we're taking the time it almost looks
like as I go through a through f
the one flows from the other and so I
don't know that you want to have and
because it's almost like a sequence of
events first I have B and then I have C
and then I have you know what I'm saying
and so if at
anytime going through that sequence you
say no then it would
stop um and so I would think I almost
like the when each of the following
requirements is met so um just if you
can maybe talk a little bit as to why
you think the or would be
better Weber yeah I I started out with
that thought um and the concern started
with first of all if if you include
where resuscitation efforts are
terminated nobody's going to be
consenting or not consenting to anything
because they're going to be dead so that
was my first concern so if we take that
bit out um first of all um C is when the
EMT and the patient agree that there's
no need for
transportation
um and I don't see that as being the
same thing as D which is refusal of
Transportation because there might be a
need for transportation but the patient
might refuse it which would be the
patient
right and the patient might refuse
Transportation um in which
case um the the issues about being
stable for referring to the physician
they might not be stable for referring
to a physician and they might not be
able to get to a physician but they
might still be refusing to be
transported so I I I don't see you can
say that all of those would necessarily
be present in every case although I
would agree with you that a lot of them
would be present in most cases so what
you're saying is as I go through the
chain of events if I stop at B and I do
not consent then CD andf are not going
to happen that's right but the ambulance
provider should still be
reimbursed yes right so okay if they've
rendered reimbursable Aid okay so you've
answer that I I I'm I'm bored that makes
sense
um the the assessment in F though of I
like I suppose you could assess mental
capacity but how is a person going to be
assessing transportation resources is
that something that needs to be in there
um um I just don't know how I'm an EMT
I'm coming on site and I'm assessing
whether or not you have adequate
transportation resources is that
so I if I may I'm assuming you ask the
patient and the patient either says yes
or no okay um and and again I think at
that
point the patients will governs because
they they may have already said I just
don't want to be transported um and
that's again why I think it should be
one or the other not all of these um
because otherwise you might go down
through all of the different steps
and say oh but I don't have any
transportation therefore you may not get
paid and I'm not sure that those should
be mutually exclusive and i' I'd be
um I I think the point about the
transportation is there for the
protection of the patient but I I I
might be persuaded to agree with you
that that shouldn't be a bar to
payment IFC which is what this bill's
about I mean we want we want the patient
to be getting the appropriate follow-up
care representative Shapiro did you have
your hand up a second ago or oh I'm
sorry okay and then I just had one last
question on your comments I promise and
I had some other questions for later but
just one last on the on the 911 call um
I'm assuming that if you don't call 911
but let's say you call an ambulance
directly or something
um
then uh you would you would just I
called them they're going to get paid
anyway because I called them is that not
already so so I I just want to explore a
little
bit because I'm thinking having a 911 if
I call them
directly I would be getting paid anyway
am I is that am I not correct on that
assumption um currently they're not
getting paid at all by
Medicaid so even if I you know what I'm
not it doesn't matter how they get there
Medicaid doesn't
pay if it's if they're not transported
okay so and I wish you might want to
actually talk to Senator Apprentice
about this because she knows a great
deal more about it being an actively
practicing EMT which is why she's so
specific about things that we were not
specific in in our formulation but um my
understanding is that there is another
category of calls and it often occurs
for people
who uh either fall regularly or have
other medical needs and and the call
comes through differently and I I am
sorry I just don't remember more about
that but I think I think the 911 call
requirement is one that in my ignorance
I find problematical because if the
service has been called out and if the
service
renders uh
assistance I think the service ought to
be paid but there may be a reason for
that being in there that I just don't
understand and I'm I'm more than willing
to be persuaded either way on it so
you're saying like a like a like you
know I need help and I fallen down and
you push the button and then they're
calling so you're saying those kinds of
calls something like that I I just don't
know enough about it I would assume that
call would be going to a 911 call but I
gather that there are calls that don't
go through the 911 system and I'm there
there probably was a reason for putting
it in and I I'd be glad if I drafted up
ah I'm seeing that Miss Dyer has
right and and my assumption without
knowledge would be that if if they got
there and all that was needed was
somebody to be helped up because they'd
Fallen uh that that wouldn't be
rendering medical treatment in any case
so it wouldn't be um reimbursable so
representative Nagel and probably have
more knowledge I don't have any
knowledge I have knowledge as a consumer
not as a as on the other side of this
but I I'm sorry I missed all this
discussion this is going to be a tad bit
egocentric
but we've been on the the visitors side
of ambulance services um and all I know
is my son got transported from one spot
to another and I got a $5,000 bill that
nobody paid for except me so I assume a
bill is being sent am I wrong and you
know maybe that Medicaid doesn't cover
it but somebody's responsible for that
bill representative Shapiro yeah I think
that for people who weren't at the
initial discussion about this this that
came up in in the in our other
discussion but really this bill only
talks to one issue which is when an
ambulance comes provides some treatment
and does not transport the person to the
patient to the hospital for a variety of
reasons um currently Medicaid does not
reimburse for that service even though
they might they came out they provided
service they might have used materials
and this bill simply says that Medicaid
will in the future reimburse it doesn't
really I know that it's a big issue
about people getting expensive bills um
either if they have private insurance or
Medicaid but this bill does not really
speak to that issue yeah I I guess my
question though is like well the bill is
still being sent to somebody
representative Weber why should I've
heard two different I've heard two
different responses to that um one was
in our initial Hearing in which uh I
think my understanding was that if a
Bill Gets Sent because the person is on
Medicaid they can't pay it and therefore
either the ambulance service if it is
private or the town if it is public pays
for everything that's unreimbursed so
yeah it's getting reimbursed but it's
getting reimbursed either by at at the
expense of other services or it's being
paid for by the
taxpayers I also did hear somebody say
that it's not even sent and I don't know
whether that's because they're on
Medicaid or or not I just don't know uh
but the fact is
that the impetus behind the bill was the
lack of reimbursement when if we amend
our plan Medicaid does reimburse these
Services if they're medically
necessary um and and it it doesn't
reimburse things like getting somebody
up after a fall you have to have
actually done an assessment of some kind
representative
Missour thank you Mr chair so and maybe
this was already discussed at some point
too but the the list of requirements who
is authorizing that all those
requirements are met so is there some
sort of sheet in the ambulance that
someone is like checking off and then
Medicaid is then contacting them to make
to make sure that all the requirements
are met representative Weber I don't
know for certain but I am pretty sure
that that's the way it would work
because that's the way all reimbursement
stuff I mean there's a huge amount of
red um um recordkeeping that is
attendant on every single call wouldn't
that wouldn't that be in the bill though
wouldn't that be mentioned somewhere
about who that and
authorization the person who is
submitting the bill would be responsible
for documenting all of those things I
mean there isn't anybody else there's
the patient and there are the medic
medical responders so um attorney Barry
do you want to weigh in on any of this
or attorney Barry I know are you with
the Medicaid unit or yeah okay thanks so
robberry general counsel for the
division of Medicaid so I'm currently
actively exchanging texts with people
trying to answer these questions in real
time uh this is more of a billing
specialist question which is not my
specialty uh but I'm trying to get you
an answer as we speak I'm also trying to
get an answer for the um the 911 call uh
language too to see if we can offer some
uh alternative language that might
satisfy everybody so I will be back
representative Shapiro thank you um in
terms of um whether to put in the bill
or not how um the services tracked
before you know so that there's evidence
that this happened I think it's just
standard it's just standard practice
when a medical provider is um billing
private insurance or public insurance
that they have to keep records which
indicate that the service was provided
that the service was medically necessary
etc etc so the really the responsibility
is on them and if they were to um Bill
Medicaid or anybody else
without you know incorrectly that would
be fraud or at least ineptitude in not
keeping proper record
so if we simply in answer to the
concern um online 11 say
something uh that uh providers shall be
eligible for Medicaid reimbursement
under their P paragraph when the
provider has documented that I mean does
that help you it it just seems to me
that there should be some sort it maybe
and I don't want to over complicate
things because that's not what I'm about
either but that there's no that we're
just kind of taking word for
it that you know are they just audibly
saying yes all these things were met I
mean cuz these are very specific
requirements you know so is someone
actually sitting in the ambulance like
check check check and yep these were and
some sort of paper trail that yes every
single one of these were met instead of
just a verbal yep we're good to go
representative would it be okay if I
just put in the words that they have to
document it and that that gives a
specific
requirement well I I mean I think that
would help personally that would you
know help but just CU this is kind of
open-ended to me it feels like there's
just this oo you know this is magically
going to
happen when there's yeah I mean for me
the providers have a huge uge amount of
documentation that they already do and
um I agree with you that documenting
that these things have happened is
important so I'm just trying to find
what language you might be comfortable
with that it would has been taken care
of Representative Nagel I think wants to
weigh in again I'm not sure where this
bill is headed but I mean it certainly
would be really helpful on documentation
issues to have feedback from the people
that are doing it cuz I'll be honest you
know it's a night May and to answer your
earlyer comment I don't Bill Medicaid a
lot because it's not worth it and I do a
lot of free care because it's not worth
it and I would imagine that there's
some something going on in here is they
don't bother either for the same reason
because the it's just the cost benefit
ratio is just not worth it
representative Shapero yeah I at least
from what we've heard or what I've heard
from my constituents I don't think
that's accurate I think the people who
provide these services are really behind
asking for this it may be inadequate but
um from their point of view inadequate
is a lot better than nothing so I don't
think it's just that people are not
billing
um um I was going to say one other thing
that seems to
have have escaped me so I'll I'll hold
off on that
one representative Weber I I too have
had extensive of discussions with my
local folks and and also the the county
folks and it's a number greater than
zero and and they're very much in favor
of it I I don't disagree with that at
all but I will tell you that in business
net revenue is the only thing and when
your cost exceeds any amount of Revenue
you get it makes virtually no sense to
bill at all and and and um you know you
do it on a case-by Case basis because I
know in some patients it's just not
worth it in other patients yeah the five
bucks over cost I'm going to gu worth it
but but but can we
agree that your model is different from
their model and it is them who asked for
this representative Shapero yeah what I
was going to say is that
um you know in my career both when I
worked at agencies I wasn't involved in
the billing but in the end of my career
when I was in private practice
um Medicaid was a low reimbursal but I
felt it was my moral responsibility to
take all insurances um and that
um so I build Medicaid a lot and um
being a small practice I did it all
myself and um you know there is a
bureaucratic burden um and it is a low
reimbursal um um but it's helpful to the
people who are providing services to get
that reimbursement plus Medicaid rates
change all the time we just increased
Medicaid rates and um I think it's very
clear when when billing Medicaid or
billing any insurance that there are
standards for documentation that have to
be met otherwise you are opening
yourself up to the liability of a
lawsuit um and if you're really just
bilding for things that um you didn't do
which we know happens that's fraud and
that's really like a serious moral and
legal um
liability
so I I I don't have any problem with
putting something in about adding
something about proper
documentation but I
think I don't know someone who's been
involved in that um part of billing and
providing Services I think there's many
other um reinforcers that um we have to
have proper documentation that Services
were provided and there was cause for
those services to be provided that they
were medically necessary I I don't think
any
provider worth their salt is that the
expression um would um function without
doing
that other comments representative mlan
then representative McKay well I think I
think the fact that we have a house bill
and a Senate bill and that the people
who are asking for the bill are actually
the people that provide the services
shows that they want to at least have
the option of you know putting the bills
in because obviously I'm going to all
these calls I'm dedicating resources to
these calls I'm providing services but
they don't go to the hospital and I I
I've just committed you know a
significant amount of Labor um with
respect to the documentation side in my
personal opinion I think we should go
with a light hand because I think you
know it's not just that the people who
are providing the services that are
going to read this bill but also the
people who are doing the reimbursement
and so if they're if you know okay they
got to do a b c d um and if the provider
isn't giving me documented proof of that
then they're just not going to do it and
so I don't know if I want to on the
front end go to the providers and and
put that burden because I think Medicaid
and of itself is going to you know I'm
more concerned to be honest with you
that Medicaid might be over ambitious
and put too many hurdles in place so I
don't know that I want to put additional
hurdles up front I think I'll leave it
to them and we'll go from there that's
my
opinion thank you sure representative uh
representative McKay was next and then
then you go ahead thank you Mr chairman
I'm still trying to get at the role of
the patient in this process and whether
there's any role at all and maybe
representative wber can help me with
this um because it seems to me that the
patients themselves should have some say
in this
process representative Weber
the bill is very clear that the patient
has a lot to do with this first of all
the patient has to be responsive because
the very first thing it says is the
patient has to consent to treatment and
evaluation if the patient doesn't is
incapable of
consenting this protocol doesn't apply
there are other protocols there are lots
of protocols but this one doesn't apply
um if the patient and the technician
agree there's no need for transport
that's the patient's
participation if the patient actively
refuses to be transported that is the
patient's
participation and the last piece is uh
the provider's evaluation about the
patient having the capacity and the
ability to follow up if they need follow
up with their own Physicians
so all of
it is with the p patient permission and
participation the evaluation end of it
appears to me to be the medical
provider and that gets me to
representative mlan point which is
that's exactly why I liked the house
formulation much better because it was
far less
specific um and
simply provided a
blanket um authorization when the
treatment was medically
necessary
um I if if this is the bill that will
pass the senate or get concurrence from
the Senate I am more than happy to work
on this bill and get it to the point
where that can happen um I I but I like
the house bill better and and I don't
know how you feel about that I don't
want to put words in your mouth but uh
your concern was a great deal of why I
like the house better if I could um that
that helps me very much thank
you uh I just wanted to point out the
the document that U Christina da just
distributed about um you know hopefully
that'll clarify some of the questions we
have and and it's my understanding that
to qualify for the $1 million in
matching funds we just have to guarantee
some form of transportation is that
correct representative Shapiro you had
your hand up I'm sorry I'm I'm not
understanding that statement because
these are when they're not
transporting oh I
see
gotcha right I gotcha
thank you thank you representative
Shapero and then representative Nagel
yes I have one
um one question and one request so my
question is
um I don't know whether this bill was
supposed to go to finance after our
committee initially it think so um but
it didn't have an appropriation and if
we pass this amendment now it will have
an appropriation so I don't know how was
it already slated to go to finance I
think it's an early bill
right okay so that was my first question
the second question is we're spending a
lot of time which is good talking about
the details of this bill and making it
um making the details work in a more
logical Manner and um hammering out
things like should documentation be in
it but I think obviously there's a whole
other issue which
is amended or not amend ended or having
the language straightened out or not the
people support the concept so I'm
wondering if before we before we end
this work session if we could perhaps
take a straw vote to see how people are
feeling about moving this bill forward
where it's going to go to finance I
suspect um as we keep hearing from
representative wer any Appropriations in
the second year of the term um are
always problematic so that's going to be
another hurdle
could we take a straw vote like before
we finish the work session to see
whether people are supportive in general
so many people are missing it's going to
be representative
Weber it's already the position of the
house cuz we already passed the other
bill that we think these services are
necessary cuz we passed
it the issue I mean we can certainly
take a straw poll I think the problem as
the chairman says is an awful lot of us
are not here uh so what what there is is
in the Senate and of course the Senate
could do what the Senate often does and
simply change our bill into their bill
and send it back to us for concurrence
or non-c
concurrence uh but
um you know my personal position
is I will be working on drafting
something that takes in into account as
much as I have heard here to the best of
my ability for presentation to the house
in case this committee decides that it
doesn't want to move this forward
because I would have that as a minority
position but it sounds to me that like
all of us are relatively in favor of it
and we just see where it goes from there
representative sh well I guess that's
what I was looking for I mean all the
discussion has been about the mechanics
of the bill and um
it's just my curiosity to to see if
there's also sentiment I mean I support
this bill after it after it will be
further amended but I'm just wondering
how other people are feeling about that
I mean we could we could straighten out
all the language and then some people
might just feel like yeah I don't want
to increase Medicaid services or we
don't have the money so I'm not going to
support this just curious going to be a
concern for I'm just curious about how
people feeling about that I guess people
don't have to say but representative
Nagel I mean my comments the contrary I
think this is an absolutely wonderful
concept I mean I just spent a week in
Kansas City discussing end of life care
and the importance of being at home um
we also know the worst place to be sick
was in the hospital so anything that we
can do to facilitate people remaining
safely in their own environment is
important and look changing the way we
look at ambulance service from a
transport service to somebody that
allows you to stay safe in your home I
think there a great change shift in
Paradigm and I think that this is is
helpful in moving us towards that and I
I I um I mean I struggled with a $5,000
bill personally which I was insulted by
so excuse my anger over that but I I
think that this is important and I think
that we really need to pursue this the
other flip side of it is you know
Medicaid is the worst insurer for
documentation and it's very frustrating
for the amount of money you get for that
and I would be happy to discuss that as
an offside thing but
um I we really don't want to overburden
the Medicaid documentation element of it
because it's already a big problem and
it does adversely affect your cost
benefit ratio and um anyways
representative Weber so here's where I'm
coming from on the overall
thing um I read the bill that we got um
initially in the house and I thought
this is a slam dunk everybody's going to
vote for this and on we go rejoicing and
I cannot believe the amount of
complication and everything else that's
going on here um is that the first time
that's
happened no no but but I I I fervently
hoped I was right about this one but I
wasn't uh which is why I just I really
want to to put in as many of the
concerns that people have so that uh the
product that we have is a good work
product and I love this because we
actually have time to work on a bill
which we often don't um and so that's
that's item number one um item number
two is I'm not at all
sure uh while I understand the logical
need for an appropriation
uh if we want to get this bill through
the house I'm not sure that agreeing to
put an appropriation in it is our best
strategy uh but then that's me trying to
second guess the finance committee which
is also never one of my strong
suits I do have a question um I mean
this is slated for executive session
later today which depending on how the
hearings go we don't know how many bills
we be get through uh is there something
you think you would have something ready
for by then or I would doubt it I mean I
I in terms of it it's going to take me a
while to do the Drafting and I have
every minute between now and 3:00 booked
and I don't think that I can get an
acceptable product to OS and get it back
by three but we have next week so right
I I realize that the more that we clear
today the better off your life is going
to be but all of us but especially me
yeah yes the clerk won't be haunting me
and and and M Miss di won't be haunting
me either or or M Davis representative
mlan know in light of some of the
comments you know of of Representative
Nagel where we're trying to keep people
at home and obviously they're providing
a service and they want to get build for
it so I think the general consensus is
yeah this is this is a good thing and I
don't want people in Ambulance Service
routinely showing up and showing up and
showing up and showing up providing a
service and not having the option to get
paid but then in in light of the
discussion that representative Missour
brought forward now that I actually see
the Senate Bill I'm kind of wondering
maybe there is too much complexity with
the Senate Bill maybe in hindsight the
house bill is a little bit better um and
if there is some real will in the Senate
to go forward with this do we just put
this one aside and let them deal with
the house bill and if they think the
house bill is too broad then they can
certainly like a representative Weber
said they can take the house bill and
turn it back into this bill
um uh and that way we
don't and I wish some of the other folks
in the committee were here so that we
could kind of flush it up but now that
we actually have the meat of the Senate
bill in front of us H so that's my
thought
maybe representative Weber and then
representative Shapiro and and I would
be glad to discuss that with Senator
apprentice and and hear her thoughts on
that I I
think based on a discussion I already
had with her because of her knowledge of
the process she's a lot more comfortable
I think with this but i' I'd be more
than willing to discuss that with her
and see if there is a strategy going
forward uh that having been said I
always think we're better off having a
house position of of any sort but I I
agree that getting this through the
finance committee is going to be a very
heavy lift at this point representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman um you
know when I first started six years ago
um I was very confused about why there
would often be the same bill from the
house and from the Senate and and this
one wasn't identical although it was on
the same subject but frequently they're
identical um and I've never gotten a
good answer for whether that's
sloppiness
strategy um gives it two chances but at
this point um from my experience with
the dental benefits bill which was
similar there were two almost very
similar bills not identical I think
we're best we have the best shot if we
pursue we've already pursued the house
bill and if we pursue this one with our
best efforts and um we'll see what
happens in the long run but I think
we're better off if we um move both of
them forward and
um you know only one will come and
become law if it becomes law so I I I
don't think we should like let this one
go I think we should um do our best job
at it and move it forward and and also
um you know while representative mlan
you said that um maybe this bill is too
complicated and the other one was
simpler and better
um at the original hearing there were
people that said exactly the opposite
which is the house bill was too simple
and this one would flush out more
details and would be a a a a more
comprehensive and therefore a better um
means of getting this done so I
think you know there are different
points of view about that so I think we
should pursue both of them personally
representative Nagel I don't know if I
had my hand up but I will say this this
is what confuses me a lot is that
um I mean Medicaid clearly articulates
expectations of me when I submit a bill
that already exists and that's why I'm
really leaning back towards your point
that maybe the other bill was fine
because everything we're talking about
here already exists in some way shape or
form the only difference is we're
legislating as opposed to they're
already doing
it other comments representative mlan I
mean I I'm just being cheeky but um
would it be almost worth it just to
amend this bill into the house bill so
um that's that's something I'm I'm sorry
go ahead that's something that Senate
has done any number of times or they the
other thing that happens at Committee of
conference time is that the bill that we
liked as the house or the bill that they
liked as the Senate gets put onto the
bill that's our top priority and comes
back um uh so there's a lot of game
playing at the end um
my preference and I I I had thought of
that as well I mean just amending it to
the house version
I think
that
the for me the best way to deal with it
is to turn the Senate version into the
best version of the Senate bill that we
can can pass if we can pass it maybe
maybe we can't pass it in which case
there is that bill still over there and
they can do what they want to do with it
and it will either come back or it won't
um but
I I feel an obligation to take this
language which which has certain things
in it that at least I object to and that
I've heard other people here objecting
to and try and straighten those out at
least as a starting point um
and I have to say that my own feeling on
it is that whichever bill will pass is
the one that I'm in favor of but um but
I can't tell which bill that is yet
representative Bill
King okay um I've been listening to a
lot of the going back and forth and um I
I in my opinion I generally support
moving forward with the best language we
can with this Senate bill just as you
had mentioned representative
Weber the um I think the the house
version we hit some snags because we
didn't like some of the language and we
wanted to do interm study and it went to
the house and it got through um and so I
think we're seeing the same thing with
this bill I will say I I will not
support any money Appropriations for a
lot of the reasons that have been
brought up and then my last comment
which is for future legislation is I
think somebody really needs to take and
this might be addressed to some of the
people in the audience we really need to
take a look at the Medicare Gates that
providers have to go through Medicaid
you mean Medicaid uh the the gates that
they have to go through in order to get
their money and so um I and this isn't
the first bill I heard this on so that's
my
opinion representative Lan um thank you
Mr chairman and I'm sorry committee
members for just arriving I was over on
the Senate HHS committee um and that is
also why the prime sponsor the bill was
unable to come over so I did speak with
her previously about this bill um I know
that one of the biggest challenges that
some people in the house have vers with
this language is they were concerned
that this wouldn't Co and I'm sorry if
any of this was covered while I was away
um was that they were concerned that
this wouldn't cover LIF assist but in a
lift assist that isn't just a transfer
into the shower or into a car or
something else that is
non-medical um when you find somebody on
the floor the first thing you need to do
before moving them is to assess them so
through throughout that whole assessment
process even in a lift assist even in
somebody who has fallen and and is
unable to get up on their themselves
because they or their spouse is not able
to get them um back up on their feet and
safe there's still going to be an
assessment there's still going to be
that process so that would meet the
general criteria of this um I do agree
that we basically have language that
says that you need to meet all of the
requirements that are internally
conflicting and I think that it would be
necessary to tease that out and figure
out sort of the categories I don't know
if you already have that language done
could I just sure representative
representative L on up to where we got
to I think so the just to deal with the
comments that we've had to date uh on
line 11 um there needs to be a little
more specifity specificity and I haven't
drafted it yet but uh it says the
providers shall be eligible for Medicaid
when each when and we're going to take
out each of the following has been um
satisfied because they're mutually
exclusive but some language about when
the provider has documented the
following which makes it clear that the
provider has to do that although we
we're pretty sure that they already have
to but let's put it in there
anyway um
the
um one of the things that still
unresolved is whether it has to be as a
result of a 911 call or not and I'd love
to talk to Senator Apprentice about that
but part of my thinking was to just
strike that one because however they got
called out they get called out and if
they have been called out and provided a
service I think they ought to be
reimbursed but there may be a reason for
that staying in that I don't know so
that's still a question mark uh it B it
ought to it has to be absolutely
mandatory that the patient has consented
to evaluation and
treatment
then
sorry but if they are inable to consent
to any of these things the whole thing
is just a completely different
protocol
um the next thing is and then then I
would say and one of the following is
exists so either C would be after the
evaluation the paramedic and the patient
agree there's not a need for
transportation I'm taking out this shall
include when when resuscitation efforts
are terminated I'm making that into a
whole another category because one of
these things is not like the other the
second one would be the patient does not
request or actively refuses and we said
or rather than and actively refuses
transport
and then I put E and F together saying
the patient is stable for referring to
the physician or other community
resource I take out is
deceased and say the p and the patient
has the ability including mental
capacity and transportation resources to
obain obain the
followup and then i' put one final one
in that is resuscitation efforts were
terminated because the uh patient is
deceased and and and that just sort of
seems to untangle it a
bit um that seems to untangle almost all
of it um except that you they may not be
consenting to the evaluation and
treatment if they're going to have
unsuccessful resusitation um efforts so
so CL so clarifying within that the
patient consents to evaluation and
treatment or um unless unless what the
new f is the case unless f is triggered
yes okay except in the case of
f representative Seth K thank you Mr
chair um in regards to the response
originated through a 911 call I might be
amenable to the idea of changing that to
an emergency call so it opens up it
opens up like if it was a Lifeline
button they pushed or something but I
would still like to keep that because um
it it precludes the idea that the
ambulance is on a on a fishing
Expedition so well and I think I'm I'm
seeing some head moving over there and
he may want to comment because he
actually knows what he's talking about I
think the other thing that people were
concerned about was making very clear
that this is not in the context of just
a routine transport so I think perhaps
something like the emergency call
language
might attorney Barry put that guideline
back in place so I had a brief
conversation with director lman um
earlier while you guys as we're
deliberating and that's something we
think we can do uh we don't have to
actually have the 911 language in there
but we would have to have some sort of
emergency language in there as well and
I'm happy to I've been writing down your
uh your comments representative Weber
I'm happy to put together some draft
legislation to start with so you can
take a look at um if that's something
you're amendable to um either that or I
can do it and send it to you you want I
I representative
Shapero um while attorney Barry is here
um before I before I had the um
Amendment um to add the appropriation
now um I did reach out to um Mr Litman
and he seemed um to say that it was
important that we added the
appropriation now in this committee I'm
not really sure why to tell you the
truth and I don't know that you would
have anything to add to that um but in
regard to representative Weber's comment
about whether
to vote on this amendment now to add the
appropriation or just vote on the policy
and send it to finance for them to deal
with the appropriation um I was
wondering the same thing and um Mr
Litman seemed to think that it was
better to do it first so I don't know if
you have anything to add to that well
the Department's position has been that
we don't have the ability to implement
this legislation without an
appropriation and that's the sooner we
can get it in there the the better
representative Weber and and I hate to
do this because it puts it off but one
of the ways of fixing it without an
appropriation is to change the effective
date to the next budget cycle well they
could still do that and they could still
do that and that's why I'd rather not do
that here um but um that's the other fix
that gets the language here puts the
department on notice that it has to go
into your um budget as as submitted to
the governor as submitted to the house
but
correct other comments other
discussion no more of
discussion right thank you attorney
Barry all right um there's nothing else
on HB 409 SB 409
FN um we'll uh we'll close this um work
session We're not scheduled to do
anything else until 11:00 a.m. at which
time we'll be hearing SB
357 so with that I will uh I we'll be in
recess
Med that's a
high National
4 in
oh really a lot of I mean there's two
reasons why number
one you know that you know I think
there
e
e e
hello everyone and welcome back to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs uh we are
now going to start our public hearings
and we have five schedule for today the
first one at 11:00 a.m. uh and I'll
recognize the prime sponsor of Senate
bill 57 Senator Whitley good morning
Senator thank you Mr chair good morning
members of the committee apologies if I
am out of breath this is my third of
fourth bills I'm introducing and that
I'm supposed to be in committee myself
representative Leon's been giving usone
your
schedule uh further record my name is
Becky Whitley I'm honored to represent
Senate District 15 which includes the
wonderful communities of conquered bow
and hopkington today I'm honored to
introduce Senate Bill
357 which should look very familiar to
you from last last year this bill is
similar to hb610 from last session which
passed both bodies but died in Committee
of conference due to a different and
unrelated issue as happens often at the
end of the year so just generally the
bill expands the definition of Provider
under the therapeutic cannabis program
to include a Prov a provider license to
prescribe medication and this is the the
piece that's a little different in the
Senate uh it was amended to um indicate
that this should be someone who is
primarily responsible for the patient
care so the bill also requires for
issuance of a registry identification
card to a minor certification from two
providers one of whom shall provide
pediatric care I want to note that this
policy was recommended by the
tcob the legislatively created body
which provides medical oversight over
the therapeutic cannabis
program um the the Senate uh supported
this bill there was little to no
controversy after we did that minor
Amendment which I believe strengthens
the bill I do have an amendment that was
requested by the Pas I'm not sure if the
committee received it we did get an
amendment okay great it is possible that
there is a drafting error so I would um
ask for the committee's patience as we
sort out that potential drafting error
um but there are folks behind me that
can speak to that Amendment and why it
is is
necessary so with that I'm happy to take
any questions we'll of course defer
technical questions to the folks behind
me thank you very very much for your
consideration of Senate Bill 357
representative blon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
bringing this back I know that um we've
also made good forward prog progress on
bail reform so it's good to see that all
the good parts from that Committee of
conference have moved forward um I I do
see that um in the drafting it's because
it replaced section four which what
should be section five but I do
appreciate and like your language with a
phys assistant so okay thank you very
much thank you for bringing this back to
us my
pleasure other
questions okay I'm seeing none thank you
okay and my apologies if I do have to
run back to committee I understand thank
you oh and sorry Senator could you fill
out a pink card for us before you leave
as well you already did perfect thank
you thank you I was waiting for me when
I came in this morning perfect
also signed up to speak is Jerry
Kar last minute conference there
okay thank you very much for the record
my name is Jerry kerk and I chair the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board um so the testimony is going
around you'll have that to take a look
at uh
now yes this is the same bill of 610
from 2023 it was a non- gerain amendment
that killed that um 610 and then this
follow-up Bill uh was a bill that was
filed at the request of the tcob which
voted unanimously to support it in case
you're not familiar with tcob it is the
uh committee which is statutorily board
statutorily charged with medical
oversight of the therapeutic cannabis
program So currently the only providers
who can certify patients to use
therapeutic cannabis in New Hampshire
are Physicians advanced practice
registered nurses and physician
assistants TCM o wishes to expand this
list to include other providers who may
be treating a patient and that's what is
done in section one of the bill when we
first talked about this and we discussed
uh we we kind of made a list of
providers we thought that we should
consider for expansion people like
naturopaths dentists podiatrists and
then we ultimately decided that rather
than making a list which can always run
the risk of leaving somebody out
ultimately it would be easier and more
straightforward to allow any provider
who's licensed to practice uh and
prescribe drugs to humans and possesses
an active registration from the US Drug
Enforcement Administration to prescribe
Controlled Substances to be allowed to
certify a patient the reason we chose
that language is that's the language
that's already in statute for each of
the provider groups currently allowed to
certify patients now the amendment from
the Senate adds the language in lines 13
and 14 that stipulate that that
qualifying provider must be primarily
responsible for the patient's care for
that qualifying condition that's
certainly reasonable even if it's uh a
physician if you're seeing a physician
uh who certifies you who wants to
certify you a specialist uh they
obviously shouldn't be special or
certifying you outside of their
specialty and in this case for example a
dentist can meet the criteria to certify
a patient to treat dental pain uh if
they're responsible for treating that
but not to qualify to treat a patient
for treatment of let's say their foot
pain because they're not the provider
for that so the idea was to keep it in
the in the proper wheelhouse section two
is a revision to reflect the reality of
Medical Care in New Hampshire because of
the unique risks of therapeutic cannabis
in children guardrails exist in statute
that a child being considered for
certification has to be certified by two
providers and the current statutory
language mandates that one of those
providers must be a pediatrician however
in many areas around our the State
particularly in rural areas there may
not be a pediatrician a child may have
as their PCP a family practice provider
who provides pediatric care so we felt
it would be best to have the child get
their second certification by the PCP
providing their Pediatric Care rather
than have to travel to see a
pediatrician who is not their provider
to be certified and the language in
lines 14 to 18 allow that um now we do
not expect that the passage of this bill
will result in a large number of new
providers to begin certifying patients
but rather what it will do is ease the
burden on patients and reflect the
realities of our Health Care system so
we'd like to ask you to please pass 357
as amended in the senate in order to
facilitate that certification I only saw
the new Amendment today and that's why I
brought up to Senator Whitley that I
think there is a drafting error because
what it in effect does again to
understand initially it was medical
docks then it expanded to ARP aprns and
then Physicians assistance were added a
few years ago the the amendment at is is
currently drafted strikes through the
language in four which is what allowed
physician assistance
to certify and it folds them
in uh to section three but section three
which then is physician PA and APRN that
has to do with our adjacent states that
was put in to allow uh those who are
certified under State Licensing Laws in
Maine mass and Vermont and part of that
is because of the fact that people may
be cared for in an adjacent area for
example I live in Conway it's a Border
Town some people may get their um their
medical care over in fryberg which is
you know Stones throw away and their doc
there might want to certify them but
they wouldn't be able to because they're
not in the right state so this was put
in to allow those adjacent State
providers to be able to certify but the
effect of this amendment as written will
remove the ability of Pas in New
Hampshire to be able to certify so we do
have to clean up the language on this
I'm not quite sure what the rational was
to put this in except perhaps to insert
physician assistant under uh three
because that was not there before it
used to be only Physicians and aprns in
the adjacent States could certify it was
an oversight when we expanded it to Pas
a few years ago that should have been
put in there so that's okay to add that
but the the language in four should not
be stricken and it should stay as a as
section five so I think it is a drafting
error and I Senator Whit and I can work
with you on that to make sure it's clear
ultimately okay representative Leon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
honorable kerk for being here and
bringing this Insight um as I'm looking
at it closer I think I spoke a little
too quickly saying that um it shouldn't
have struck that out um I guess the
biggest thing is we seem to have an
emerging change in physic physician
assistants in their scope of practice so
the I think the question becomes if
physician assistants need to be
practicing under supervising physician
still because if they do then we need to
have them operate we may need to have
them with the language in four unless we
wanted to open that up to them anyways
and if we wanted to move the language
ahead and simply allow a physician
position I assistant or APRN to license
to prescribe drugs then that clarifies
it um but I'm starting to wonder if
we're still leaving too many segments in
here if we're looking at a physician
physician assistant advanced practice
registered nurse or and other New
Hampshire provider licensed to prescribe
drugs to humans and who presents this
I'm wondering if it all can actually
consolidate into simply one paragraph
that takes into effect all of this and
I'm curious to'd be willing to try and
work on that we actually
kind of talked about that I mean this is
just gradual creep uh and again it was
initially written as medical providers
and then the APNs were added Pas were
added and so each time we just added new
section and they are rather equivalent
language in each one of them uh that is
that they can treat humans and so on and
so forth except the PA language I know
there is a bill that is considering
getting rid of the supervision uh issue
and if that passes of course then this
would have to be updated anyway but
that's how come it has this cumbersome
structure and we did wonder about just
going with the current language any New
Hampshire provider licens provide drugs
to humans and so on and so forth that
language that is currently in uh the
beginning of the bill or in lines 12 to
16 of the of the amendment and I think
that could work because then that would
cover all
providers
um and you still have to have this
separate uh issue for
the no actually sorry back up that would
that would muddy the water just a wee
bit perhaps because
um if you say it has to be the person
primarily responsible for patient's care
related to the qualifying medical
condition all right so let's say your
primary care doc wants to actually uh
certify you to use uh therapeutic
cannabis for back pain and you're seeing
a back specialist well that back
specialist is really primarily
responsible for your back issue but your
PCP should still be the one who is
allowed to do it so
I you can see why we we debated this and
we could never come up with a good
solution decided just to add one more
one more section but I think it could
conceivably be scaled down to being the
language
um that uh let me get it up here the
language that currently exists one two
three could all be condensed
into one but then you still want five
separately because because that gets
those other providers who are hate to
say this but sort of peripheral
naturopaths dentists
podiatrists um because again we're we're
stipulating their the primary
responsibility and that's not what it
says in the other ones so there are
wording issues here followup
representative L and as a followup I
think I now see why you settled on the
general language of the amend Amendment
from Senator Whitley I think we should
scan it for any other typos that are
actual typos and not content as I
misunderstood yeah I mean it needs to be
looked over a little more closely and
unfortunately
our our administrator uh Michael Holt
who's the administrator is out on
medical leave right now and so I really
can't even clarify this cleanly with him
um but I can certainly speak with
Senator Whitley about this issue a
little bit more too again I just got I
just got handed this an hour ago so I
was unaware representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
doctor for um taking
questions the the ACT is relative to
expanding the definition of providers
and I'm glad you spoke more about
section subsection five um because that
last part there that you also touched on
a little bit um more recently who is
primarily responsible for the patient's
care related to his or her qualifying
medical condition to me that just seems
like it's in contradiction to the rest
of the objective of the Bill of
liberalizing things that to me seems
like it would make things much more
conservative and it would put roadblocks
in the way of patients being able to get
the care that they need because you know
yeah you might have a general
practitioner and you might even have a
specialist for your back pain but Mo
both of them might be extremely
conservative and have very negative
views of cannabis and they might not be
willing to give you something so that's
where going to like a holistic doctor
might be the option for you to get
access to cannabis and to me I'm
concerned that this would this would
negate that ability and also you know I
I'm a firm believer that medicine you
can't just you can't
just dissect the anatomy of the body and
say well this is a hand problem
therefore only hand doctors can help you
um the whole body is connected you know
um what goes on in your gut health can
affect your heart health it can affect
you know your brain I mean it can do a
lot so so I don't know that section
there that part I just feel like is very
concerning to me what are your thoughts
on that thank you well your comments are
very correct and indeed that language
was not initially in it was added at the
behest of one of the Senators who wanted
to have a little more restriction on it
and um we sort of accepted it uh I think
realize that the words primarily
responsible is a little
squishy um in the sense that it doesn't
say so responsible for example and you
could argue that if you've gone to an
naturopath for treatment of a particular
disorder because you're not pleased with
how you're moving along with your uh
standard uh medical provider you are
actually asking that naturopath to take
responsibility for your care so then
that as I understand would be acceptable
there was again I wish um my cult were
here because there was some conversation
with opcc about oplc about that at one
point and apparently that's they they do
view it as somewhat squishy as well I
hate to use the word squishy but it's
kind of a true but um so I think it
could be okay and the idea was again
that we were getting to the fact that we
didn't want the dentist to
certify for the foot pain that just
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
whereas your PCP I mean remember the
reason we have aprns Pas and medical
provid
they all could be your primary provider
uh my primary provider is an APRN she
not a medical doctor and so if she were
going to certify me the fact she's an
APN would not should not interfere with
her ability because she's my primary doc
but if I were seeing somebody else about
back pain let's say and they want to
desertify me uh they should be able to
do that and if they're
a orthopedic surgeon that is they're
going to fit no problem if they're an
naturopath they just have to say yeah
I'm taking care of for your back pain
and some naturopaths actually do care as
primary providers for some people as
well I actually when this all came up I
contacted one of our naturopaths in town
to quickly check with her and she was
comfortable and also said that if
somebody comes to see her for treatment
she's viewing that she's primarily
responsible she's not just a consult
she's actually responsible for that
follow up follow up um you mentioned the
possibility of say the dentist uh
certifying for foot pain um is that is
that a problem we're actually seeing a
lot of or is that this is solution in
search of a problem that doesn't really
exist thank you no we're not seeing it
because they can't certify anyway
they're not they're not uh they don't
fit the criteria for certifying so we
are not seeing something it doesn't
occurred but we were trying to preempt
somebody treating outside of their
specialty you could with all the respect
assume that if somebody started doing
that their Board of registration might
uh do disciplinary action for practicing
outside the scope of their
specialty other
questions seeing done okay thank you
thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on S SP 357 does anyone else wish to
testify okay um did somebody give me the
blue sheet over there um Christina or or
could you just let us know how many
signed up for and
against 54 Z against okay and
representative lon's looking up online
thank you very
much and online is eight and support
zero oppos zero
neutral okay thank you uh no one else
has signed up and apparently no one else
wishes to testify so I'm going to close
the public hearing on SB
357 our next hearing is scheduled for 1
pm. at which time we will hear testimony
on sb419 FN we stand in
recess oh excellent I see it okay
so I was coming from how are
you
e
e e
good afternoon
everyone welcome back to the house
committee on Health and Human Service
and La
Affairs the next bill that we'll be
considering today is sb419 FN and I see
he's already positioned Senator Ganon
welcome as the prime sponsor of the Bill
thank you McDonald I'm Senator Bill
Ganon I represent District 23 commonly
known as the wine country in my neck of
the woods uh from Chester to Seabrook uh
come visit and you can visit me at
zorino Vineyards it's a little plug for
them I do it everywhere um I'm here
today to introduce the
bill no oh yes oh I went over my time
thank you for having me you all have a
good day tip your
waitresses definitely I'm gonna keep
going
anyway apologize that's okay
commissioner Eddie Edwards um had me
bring this bill forward as did the
police Chiefs um they wanted to keep
track we don't have any
data right now on um so it's a data
collection instrument it was much more
broad originally but we've trimmed it
down to just the third section because
we don't know anything about violations
discovered enforcement actions taken
hearings that were held or corrective
actions so we just want to have more
data um on the therapeutic cannabis
program containment rule violations so
that's all the bill is doing now very
limited in scope compared to its
original intent
okay any questions for Senator
Ganon represent
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so it looks like
there's a lot of um you're adding a lot
of uh bear with me I just had one so
sorry um so you're going after a lot of
information out of the atc's um was
there a a discrepancy or a concern or um
something that just felt we had no data
at all so originally I I I was much more
ambitious with the police Chiefs
originally in this bill and um I'm very
concerned with Road use THC Road use not
being able to you know measure it uh so
I had other plans um there are states
that have limits and I was going after
another Avenue with the majority of the
bill uh we decided it wasn't feasible
and this worked good for commissioner
Edwards to collect data that they feel
is necessary on the
dispensaries okay other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you Senator thank you very much
for having me have a great day yeah you
too you're my favorite house committee
now oh
okay you say that oh I'm sorry Senator
Senator I'm sorry representative Nagel
I'm just
oh that that dry sense of humor can be
deadly
all right I have no one else signed up
to speak on sb419 FN I have one oh
there's
one okayy Abby Rogers from the
Department of Health and Human
Services thank you representative Paz
off good afternoon my name is Abby
Rogers I'm the legislative leison for
the division of Public Health Services I
am representing the therapeutic cannabis
program today which serves 14,000
patients in the state um Mike Colt is
generally the subject matter expert he
is out today so I am taking his place to
provide some information where I can on
sb419 um generally we are not but we're
not taking a position on the bill but I
wanted to share that uh the department
certainly is supportive of data
transparency uh the information that is
currently provided um or that is being
proposed to be added to the annual
report is currently required by
administrative Rule and it is posted
conspicuously in each ATC dispensary
location so that program regist
registrants have easy um current access
to this important information um it is
important to be transparent around the
number of inspections uh conducted
complaints received uh investigations
conducted statements of findings issued
plans of Correction received and
enforcement a actions taken but is not a
standard practice to make public in an
annual data report the substance of
those documents um our requirement for
this type of information to be published
in this manner would be inconsistent
with other areas of the department uh
where inspections are conducted for
example food food protection health
facility licensing Etc
um and uh we feel like certainly all the
information would certainly be available
through a right to no request um and
this is consistent with other health um
facility licensing programs um I believe
that Mr Hol has provided some uh
Curative Amendment language proposal to
um a member of the committee I think
representative Lon potentially on how we
might be able to address this in this
bill um I don't see her here so um I can
let you know her fill you in on that but
um certainly we want to provide be as
transparent as possible and I think that
the Curative language would just um
clarify the bottom half of the bill to
be consistent with you know instead of
saying um the statements of find like to
require actual statements of findings it
would be limited to like the number of
statements of finding
um but um I'm sure she can she can feel
you here she is now perfect so amendment
that Michael Hol may have offered you um
yes um if it hasn't come in then it's
down with Karen so I can go get that
okay so I was just finishing up with our
last right so I'm happy to take any
questions if you have any for me any
questions for M Rogers representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um have you
had any uh contact with the folks at the
atc's to get any feed Fe back um from
them um are they basically in support of
the admitted language that you're
talking about or just do you have any
insight with what their uh response is
to that from your discussion uh I have
mentioned that there was an amendment
that Amendment language that was suppli
uh provided to representative L but I
believe there's a representative from
the atcs here could probably speak to
that better than
me thank you you're welcome anyone else
any other questions or
comments seeing none thank you very much
okay once again I I don't have any other
uh print cards no one else has signed up
to testify does anyone else wish to test
representative Weber I was just going to
say before you close I if there are is
something going around we perhaps might
need to say something about it okay
before we end and and especially while
the department is still here it would be
nice to know that this is the language
that they wanted because none of the
rest of us have heard anything about it
so okay no I was just wanted to make
sure if anyone else was here to testify
fing forward but um yeah the amendment
is coming around I just didn't want to
close the hearing because then we sure
sure are there any extra copies of the
actual bill is introduced
anywhere Miss Dyer is getting one for
you oh they what oh
okay Miss Rogers do you have a copy of
the amendment I do okay yes thank you it
it have you had a chance to review it uh
yes I have um and what it what it does
uh provided by Mr Holt really keeps
intact the the original section of the
bill up until um I believe
[Music]
um it adds the word um the number and
the number in front of what was the
number of statements and the number of
alternative treatment center plans for
the original bill so it instead of
having the statement of findings and and
the the um alternative treatment center
plans it adds it to more aggregate the
number of um statements of findings and
the number of alternative treatments
that are plans of Correction which does
correlate with use of that word the
number in the previous part of the um
the
bill representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you so much for being
here um and for standing in uh my my
question is just to clarify um in the
way the bill is originally written
saying the statements of findings that
were issued that would read that the
entire statement of findings and the
entire record would be something that's
put into the into the record which is
not done with any other industry would
that be correct that's correct I did uh
I don't know if you're in the room when
I mentioned that that's not a practice
generally that we do with in any HHS
reporting including for food protection
um and and other entries it it wouldn't
just be a standard practice for us thank
you
sure other
questions seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak and I can't
quite make out the last name but Matt
from Green Leaf cannabis Matt Simon oh
okay I'm not sure how you get Simon out
of that but I've seen him a few times
before so I know it's Matt Simon thank
you Mr chairman I apologize for my poor
penmanship wasn't planning to testify on
this one just an observation not a
criticism if you've seen my my
penmanship I have no room to understood
so for the record Matt Simon I work for
granite Leaf cannabis
uh we don't have a position on this bill
I I haven't seen the
amendment uh overall I think the
department is been very forthcoming
anytime there's been a request for data
the department publishes an annual data
report and has been very responsive I
think to legislators who have requested
data but I see no objection to uh the
concept of this bill and I'll trust you
to get the details right thanks
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you for being here
Mr Simon um do you think that it's
important to make sure that the details
of any particular investigation aren't
all published publicly in a way that's
inconsistent with the rest of the way
the the department operates I would
agree with that thank you thank
you other
questions representative
Plaza I have a question to the chair
would it be appropriate to execute this
bill today no no it we just U it's not
not it's not noticed um and I I don't
sense that we're ready to do that we
take the permission of both sides to do
that I'm not ready I'd like I'd like I'd
just like to make sure to make sure I
didn't have a typo in this um I had it
sent over with language that was was
from the department but I haven't done a
specific side by side so if I have an
and or an or or something that's wrong I
don't want us to then have to clean up
afterwards and I would
defer okay
sure I think we're close but I also get
no sense that this one one is going to
take us any length great length of time
once we get to the end so I don't think
so either and it's not an early bill
either
so okay any other questions thank you Mr
Simon Okay does anyone else wish to
testify on sb419
FN okay uh and I don't know uh could I
see the blue sheet uh could someone give
me the blue sheet
sorry to keep doing that to
you thank
you no one signed up for or against on
the blue
sheet and I'm looking I forgot that uh
Senate bills and house bills are just by
number uh one and support zero oppos
zero
neutral okay with that I am closing the
public hearing on SB 419 FN uh the next
bill to be heard is sp505 and that is
not until 1:30 so we will be in recess
for about U 13
minutes a lot of
time I know let's go play kickball what
let's go play kickball read Four Square
I love Four
Square
e
e e
and recognize in lie of Senator avive
the prime sponsor Grant bossy and you're
the Deputy Chief of Staff of the Senate
right that is correct okay welcome Mr
bossy Mr chairman and members of the
committee glad to be back before HHS I
am grant bosy for the New Hampshire
Senate introducing Senate Bill 505 on
behalf of Senator Kevin avar the Bill's
Prime sponsor last year the legislature
passed HB 611 which clarified that New
Hampshire law did not authorize hemp
derived products with a THC
concentration greater than
0.3% on a dry weight basis this was
necessary to fix a gap in the 2018
Federal farm bill which legalized hemp
but was not intended to legalize THC
products like Delta 8 THC had stepped
through this loophole which HB 611
closed but that bill contains a
prospective repeal which would take
effect in October Senate Bill 505 would
repeal the repeal and keep the
clarification of high concentration THC
products in New Hampshire statute once
again this bill has no change in current
New Hampshire law it keeps the current
law on the books past the current sunset
of October 2024 if you have any
questions I'll be sure to get them to
Senator avard and make sure he gets you
an answer Senator avard thanks you for
your consideration and support of Senate
Bill 505 thank you thank you
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
coming to introduce the bill um House
Bill 611 had been a bill on a different
topic and um that this ban had been
amended in in the Senate um do you know
how much of an opportunity the house had
to weigh in on the policy of this prior
to a committee of conference I don't
know I know it was accepted in Committee
of conference
thank you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you this is a reminder I've heard others
may want to testify but I don't have all
I've only got two uh Pink cards so um if
I if you need to get me one please do so
uh next up to speak is Kate fry from new
futures
good afternoon members of the committee
I'm the vice president of advocacy at
new Futures my name is Kate fry um as
described by the previous pre uh speaker
it's a pretty straightforward bill um
it's repealing a sunset um of a of a um
law last year that was passed so um as
you know new futures um we appreciate
the opportunity to testify we uh work on
health policy issues um so one of the
issues that we often work on are um
alcohol and drug problems um we want to
thank senator avard for sponsoring this
important piece of legislation um this
particular issue that you'll hear a lot
about is these Delta 8 Delta 9 THC
products they're often marketed as a
less potent alternative to marijuana and
are some of the faster growing product
segments in cannabis Market due to a
loophole in the federal hemp bill um
delta8 or Delta 9s are sold as inhalable
smokable inestable products including
Edibles capsules oils tinctures and they
are increasingly sold in convenience
stores and gas stations right here in
New Hampshire these products pose
potential health risk both CDC and the
uh FDA have issued warnings of ser ious
Adverse Events um hemp derve THD
products again they are unregulated and
they often have brightly colored
packaging that appeals to younger
audiences and alarmingly these type of
uh as I said are popping up more and
more in uh convenience stores and gas
stations in new New Hampshire with zero
regulation I just want to be clear
there's no regulation of these
products last year new futurist worked
with Partners in support of a bell that
prohibited the sale of these products
containing the hemp derive products like
Delta 8 Delta 9 Governor sonunu signed
the bill into law however the law has a
Sunset date of October
2024 if the prohibition is not continued
after this date we'll continue to see a
proliferation of these unregulated
products um to be sold here in New
Hampshire so s sp505 to be very clear it
looks to permanently ban these products
from New Hampshire shelves we ask you to
uh vote ought to pass on this bill I
have written testimony and then I have
information about these products from
the public health law Center this is not
an issue unique to New Hampshire uh
several states have um had to uh deal
all states have been dealing with this
um either through their maybe
legalization bills or a separate um
pieces of legislation that would do
prohibitions so I'll provide that
information to you representative Lon uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
for being here to testify on this um my
I'll have a followup to this do you know
um what hearings this had in the house
or if it was only dealt with in the
committee of conference so there was and
when you brought this up I I tried to
jog my memory so this was a separate
bill in the
Senate um and then I believe it did have
it did have a house Committee
hearing um separately just on the bill
alone and I want to say it was maybe it
was 611 maybe it was something else and
then through those confusing times a
couple other amendments got added to it
but there were uh hearings on the bill
specifically that particular bill in
both the Senate and the house okay and
there a followup followup um thank you
and are you aware that as part of the
committee of conference um the reason it
was included as a Sunset date was
because the commission that was
established by that same Committee of
conference was charged with in including
these derivatives along with their their
cannabis legalization model yes so you
just drog my memory that was I believe
one of the reasons unfortunately that
didn't happen and I think the idea was
let's put this office part of our larger
regulatory schedule that's why we can um
repeal it or let it sunset in October
but it's not it hasn't happened yet I
don't know if we'll have a larger
regulatory Market by that time so our
suggestion is to you know keep the
prohibition get rid of the sunset and
when we are ready to address it in a
larger regulatory manner then that can
be in that bill alone but I just feel
it's unsafe to say okay it sunsets let's
try to get another bill in I mean what
if there's a gap so I would just rather
go with this keeping the probation on
the books thank you representative palaz
off uh thank you uh Mr chair and thank
you for the taking my question
so uh my understanding from testimonies
is that um those derivatives are being
uh widely sold it means that it creates
Revenue it creates uh uh work places uh
it creates jobs so what negatives are we
seeing from those derivatives that
require us to kill those jobs people are
getting very from these products they're
not regulated by the FDA and kids are
getting their hands on them so that is
what the outcome is I can't speak to how
much revenue these products bring in um
even the alternative treatment centers
are very wary of these products wouldn't
want to sell them so I don't think that
um certainly the revenue is um enough if
anything's ever enough to take that over
somebody's life or
well-being other questions
seeing done thank
you do you have written testimony yeah
okay great thank
you also signed up to speak is Matt
Simon from Granite Leaf um
cannabis thank you for your thank you
for
the players spelling of your last name
they do a better job writing it that
time excellent excellent I would have
remembered anyway but very good thank
you Mr chairman H again for the record
Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis um
so yeah I've been an advocate for
legalizing natural cannabis THC products
for more than 15 years so it puts me in
a little bit of a strange situation to
be supporting a bill like this uh but I
do support for reasons I'm happy to
explain uh THC
products should be regulated and the
proliferation of hemp derived synthetic
THC products that have been coming out
since this loophole was created by the
by the farm bill a few years ago are not
regulated uh so nobody really knows
what's in them and as I mentioned these
are actually synthetic products
uh they are not natural cannabis
products hemp companies are growing
fields of hemp they are harvesting the
CBD from the hemp and then they are
soaking the CBD in an acid that converts
the CBD into whatever the desired THC
variant
is uh it turns out you can convert CBD
into delta9 THC that's the one people
who use cannabis are familiar with you
can also convert it into Delta 8 THC
Delta 10
THC THC acetate thcp THC JD and a whole
bunch of other thc's that I'd never
heard of until within the last year or
two these novel THC isomer variant as
they're referred to in in the law and
and this
bill most of them have never really been
tested on humans some of them are
reportedly far more potent than natural
THC so THC for example I have a thcp
vape right here I read on the internet
that thcp is 30 times more potent than
Delta 9 THC I don't know if it's true or
not but I know I bought this in
conquered and I wasn't carded to buy it
and I would not inhale this product
because I have no idea what it
is uh there is more of a risk with Vape
products than other types of cannabis
products that's why it's so important
that cannabis Vapes
be regulated any impurities any
contaminants that are either on the
Cannabis or in the oil that's created
from the Cannabis or that are byproducts
of the synthetic conversion
process any of that will be concentrated
into the oil that goes into the Vape
cartridge and then it'll be inhaled by
the consumer so for that
reason we are very comfortable with the
idea of having all of these products
have to be independently lab tested
everything we sell at the atcs has to be
lab tested every single batch as the way
we were able to assure patients that
they're not inhaling dangerous chemicals
uh there's simply no way for us to
regulate these products they're being
made in other states they're being sold
in New Hampshire the federal law is a
murky gray area our state law does not
have to be a murky gray area I think the
law that passed last year is a very good
start I think it could be
perhaps improved upon but the goal was
just to make sure these products are not
being sold in gas stations convenience
stores places where kids can easily
access them we can't stop people from
getting these products or using them I
wouldn't want a criminal prohibition I
wouldn't want people to be arrested for
this you can order them online have them
delivered to your house but do we want
them in the convenience to our next to
the high school and my concern is that
any negative impacts that come from
these synthetic
THC drugs uh will end up reflecting
negatively on cannabis so for example
when
somebody Vapes some thcp and has a
negative incident they'll call Poison
Control or go to the emergency room and
that'll end up being blamed on cannabis
legalization when in reality it's an
incredibly irresponsible policy federal
policy that allows these products to be
produced and distributed so again we
can't fix federal law but I would urge
you to pass this and repeal the repeal
until such time as we're able to
regulate regulate these
products thank you questions
representative Nan thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question I just
have I'm confused um so it's illegal
until like next week
correct the the ban is until next week
it doesn't matter I believe it's the end
of the year oh October but you bought
that uh over a year ago I've been
carrying this around for a while Sor
confused thanks I believe the lior
commission will tell you that there are
still sales happening that there's the
businesses are getting terrible legal
advice basically their lawyers are
telling them these products are ferally
legal all the products have disclaimers
on them they say it's less than. 3% THC
it's not uh you know this one for
example is 92% Delta 8 THC but it claims
to be fully compliant with the farm bill
so you know that don't believe
everything you read on a label of a
product you're planning to inhale would
be my advice to anybody by things that
are produced and regulated systems and
uh cannabis advocacy organizations like
normal for example normal is the the
organization that advocates for cannabis
consumers rights and they oppose these
these products they think any product
with THC in it should be regulated for
the safety of consumers so I don't see
this as a freedom issue I don't even see
it as a cannabis issue I see it as more
of an e of the synthetic drug debates
that we've had previously in this in
this body uh and this is just another
synthetic work around people want
natural cannabis and they're settling
for this stuff because natural cannabis
isn't legal yet
thanks other
questions representative McLean thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so um I'm just trying to so
around us other states
is is
this are there similar bands in other
states like Vermont Massachusetts around
us and so uh since the ban has go in
place if that's the case is there other
places that uh people can go to I
understand that that is not a regulated
product but I'm assuming it's
manufactured in a factory um
so can you maybe talk to what is the the
the fabric around us in terms of
Regulation and also so the safety of
that relative to maybe some Street Delta
8 THC did you have any feel for
that thank you for the question so this
is a very emerging area of policy states
are scrambling to deal with it they're
dealing with it in different ways
Vermont expressly prohibited all uh hemp
derive THC unless it is specifically
approved by the the Cannabis control
board so they invite company if you want
to sell one of these products you just
submit it to the for for approval and
they they have to approve it and if they
approve it you can sell it I don't know
if they've approved anything or not but
that's I think that is an incredibly
responsible approach to regulating these
products I think they need to be if
we're if we're going to have seed to
sale regulation of natural cannabis that
these products should be held to at
least that standard if not a much higher
standard and in fact some of these
specific products probably should never
be legal I mean they're frankly they
might be very dangerous we don't know uh
when I see something's 30 times more
potent than Delta 9 DHC I I get a little
bit
concerned well just just to kind of
clarify so from a harm reduction
perspective if I'm looking one of the
selling points of legalizing cannabis is
we're going to have nice safe not laced
with fentanyl cannabis and so that's
that's the push so what I'm trying to
understand is that product there that
you have on your desk relative to Street
even though that's not regulated in the
same way is there are they both the same
in other words they're they're both is
deadly or not as deadly or you have
basically because it's so new you have
no data I guess is the question from a
harm reduction perspective the only way
to know what is in this Vape cartridge
is to have it tested by an independent
lab and there has been uh there have
been groups that have gone around buy
buy a bunch of these take them to the
independent lab have them tested the
results are all over the place so some
of the products are actually what they
say they are and they don't contain
terrible contaminants but an awful lot
of them do have very dangerous
contaminants very shocking levels uh and
for that matter the the Delta 8 content
is often labeled very inaccurately uh
there's very often Delta 9 THC even
though there's not supposed to be uh
these are being produced in States like
Florida and
where it's easy to get a license to be a
hemp grower and it's easy to produce
these products and there's no
requirement for lab testing so they're
complying with state laws and they're
complying at least with their lawyers
advice on what federal law is uh again
we can't fix that these aren't New
Hampshire companies making these
products I don't know of any New
Hampshire company that's that's making
these products but uh we have retailers
who are in the position of companies are
trying to say hey sell this sell this
it's it's great it's legal and it isn't
we need that Clarity in state law so
that retailers know what they can and
can't do thank you thank you
representative Paz off thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so I I'm here in previous
testimony in question I here about
taking somebody's life and about deadly
products so do we have any data how many
New Hampshire residents are dead because
of poison
by this modified th THC derivatives or
maybe National
statistics yeah so there are statistics
from other states I don't I I think it's
very hard for somebody in poison control
or somebody in an emergency room to know
whether the product that somebody
consumed was a natural cannabis product
or a synthetic THC product a lot of
people I talk to think these are natural
products they're using them every day
and they think it's a natural cannabis
product it's not so
I think it just gets reported at the
emergency room as uh this person used
cannabis or marijuana I think poison
control is probably the same way so it's
really hard to disambiguate uh that data
but there have certainly been an
increase in in calls to poison control
and uh issues associated with these
products uh Nationwide uh since since
the farm bill and it's just hard to pin
down how big that increase is because it
coincides with can cannabis becoming
more available as well other
questions representative
Nel thank you Mr chairman thanks again I
I we had this discussion earlier but I
just feel obligated to point out the
same problems occur with CBD in terms of
marketing and verification and you know
you already know that but I just feel it
it's a it's a it's a big problem and we
really need to be more responsible so I
guess I'm not supposed to make a
statement but I just did
I would believe that representative Nel
thank
you other
questions seeing none thank
you the only other pink card I have is
from Beth sergeant from the New
Hampshire Association of state of chiefs
of
police so I kept you as far last as I
could
good afternoon chairman McDonald members
of the committee my name is Elizabeth
Sergent I work for Shan finny uh Capital
group here in conquered I'm here today
representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police in
support of this bill and I was totally
cheating by asking to go last because I
was hoping someone would be able to um
explain this more clearly so the uh we
would agree with the testimony from new
Futures and with Matt um I simply want
to hand in our testimony in support of
the bill um what I've presented is our
testimony also a couple of handouts
based on what you've heard today uh
things to know about Delta 8 um and also
I did include um I included an article
about increases in availability of
cannabis products containing Delta 8 THC
and reported cases of Adverse Events and
I did include House Bill uh
611 um I didn't have the Senate Bill
representative lay on but I do have the
house bill that is there so you can see
where the there would be a prospective
repeal this fall um and I guess also to
answer the there is some data in here
from our testimony from last year the
FDA received 104 reports of Adverse
Events in patients who consumed delta8
THC products between December 1 2020 and
February 28 2022 so a little bit ated of
these 104 Adverse Events reports 77%
involved adults 8% involved pediatric
patients less than 18 years of age and
15% did not report age and it went goes
on to give some information about how
many required intervention um Adverse
Events just to continue to show how
dangerous these products are included
but we're not limited to hallucinations
vomiting Trevor Tremor anxiety dizziness
confusion and loss of
Consciousness um and I think um that's
it um we did explain a little bit about
the farm bill of 2018 and the fourth
paragraph as well so with that if I can
answer a question I'd be happy to but
conclude my testimony representative Paz
off thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I wonder if some
of the problems that we heard uh about
could already be addressed with
uh whether it's repealed or not because
my understanding if the Delta 9 is uh
regulated and if the if the label says
it's delta8 but if there significant
amount of Delta 9 it's probably already
illegal to sell it and similar if there
are some if it says Delta 8 but if there
are some uh contamin
contamination in the product that uh
creates vomiting or some other uh
adverse effects for the clients I think
it would be already illegal to sell
something with uh harmful
contaminants well I think our testimony
is that it's unregulated now and we're
concerned for the safety of our citizens
so we would for now want to keep the
prohibition in place thank you other
questions representative Lon uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you so much
for being here thank you for including
the final language of 6112 sure it's a
good reminder of everything that came
out of that Committee of conference yeah
um do you know if there was a separate
Senate bill or if it was only heard as
part of an amendment to 6 when you ask
Kate I'm sorry that I forgot to ask Mr
Simon that I've been searching on the
database to see if there was something
for him I looked too I couldn't find it
but I know there was it was Senate Bill
180 oh 180 okay thank you I couldn't
find out I didn't know if it had a
different name in the title
in
180 was it 2022 or 20 um if so last year
so
2023 okay and this was signed into law
yeah this is 20123 as well yeah I
remember I I was on I Shar conference so
I definitely remember that I just don't
remember it having a hearing so thank
you I will look into that because um it
was a pretty big policy change which is
why we sunsetted it but thank you very
much for bringing the issue of
Regulation to us thank you so much other
questions saying none thank you thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 505 does anyone else wish
to
testify they seeing no one uh Christina
could you possibly let us know the blue
sheet I'm sorry to keep dragging you up
here
could always make it into like a paper
airplane
and oh because stud oh thank you okay on
the blue sheet in the back four people
signed up uh all in favor no one signed
up against and online we'll find out in
a
moment sorry I naviga way Page I just
need to pull it back up sure
um online there were 23 in support and
four opposed and um actually you mind if
I just say one other thing from the
committee of conference um so the reason
that the Sunset date was on this was
because the committee of conference took
the one that expanded it from just from
the pain so you wouldn't have to have
spine surgery or try opioids before
having cannabis as an option this had
the commission there was charged with
drafting legalization for cannabis
legalization on it and that was supposed
to include um regulations on hemp
derived products and that's why as a
good faith effort there was an intention
that that was supposed to be included in
the legal in the legislation for
legalization and that was one of the
charges to that commission so the fact
that it's come separate and and there
wasn't a bill filed um you know this
really is I think intimately tied with
cannabis legalization because these
really only exist because people don't
have access to cannabis in the state so
that's why there was a sunset so thank
you okay with that I am going to close
the public hearing on S SP 455 FN excuse
me uh s
sp505 and open the public hearing on S
SP 455 two minutes two minutes oh well
it's 202 there I thought so it's like 1
minute by Apple okay all right we'll be
in recess for two minutes gra one
need to have we'll need to have
facilities fix that
clock I once nipped up to fix the clock
and leapt up on a chair and tried to
pull it down so I could fix it realized
it was hardwired into the electric wire
and I very nearly ripped the live wires
out of the back of the clock so I don't
touch anything like that anymore sorry
for my freak out earlier I don't know is
I the only one that heard that
it it was a fairly loud noise and it was
in fact in my younger days I used to go
to conventions and a standard part of
the convention was that somebody was out
of the fire alarm so I I learned to just
sleep for those things Unfortunately
they were all always bogus uh if that
been real I never would have made it
up and it's an interesting point I mean
we used to do drills evacuating this
building and the other thing is that
there are certain rooms that are shelter
in place rooms for people with no
mobility issues and we don't we haven't
talked about that for a number of years
now yeah I've been here this is my
fourth year I've never had we've never
had a fire drill since I've been here
well representative salaway is no longer
on this committee because he would have
insisted on one but uh it it was
actually mentioned to the speaker
recently as as something that perhaps we
be going back to
because um I when I started it was in
this room and the committee was chaired
by representative David Cody who had
significant mobility issues and for whom
getting downstairs would have been I was
on two I was on two committees with him
last term I've never met him except on
except on zoom and and he he but there
was a room and it used to be prominently
posted
said shelter in place and that was the
room that the conquered fire department
knew to check that window first because
that's where people that needed help
getting out would be so and and I just
we haven't talked about it at all since
so the the term after that I was on Edna
and I had two EMTs on the committee and
I figured if anybody had Mobility
problems they' they'd be dealing with it
and getting them out so it was not going
to be my personal responsibility to make
sure people
were taken care
of okay back staircas is that does that
open up it comes out it's it's comes out
over the lob parking garage onto the
deck of the parking garage and the only
thing you need to know is you're not
coming back that way unless you because
it's not keyed or anything once it
closes and closes you have to come back
in the door and start over again we can
go from this side we can go we can go
out and I often do because I fortunate
enough to be
parked right under where the table we
s okay I think we're I know it's over
after two now
so okay let's
reconvene and um the next bill up it is
after 2:
p.m. uh next up is Senate Bill 4555 FN
and I'll recognize the prime sponsor uh
Senator Apprentice
welcome chair McDonald and members of
house Health and Human Services and
elderly Affairs my uh I I look at you as
my kind of like brother sister committee
as I work on the Senate side with Health
and Human Services um thank you for the
opportunity today to introduce
Senate Bill 455 for the record my name
is Suzanne Apprentice I am the state
senator from District 5 covering a large
part of Grafton County a little bit of
Sullivan County and one town in marac
County the beautiful uh town of New
London so first I just want to tell you
a little bit about why this bill is of
interest to me in my so I'm and some of
you I've spoken with you before you know
that I have a background as a paramedic
but in my my
full-time work with a not for profit for
The Last 5 Years called the American
trauma Society I've been working with
the trauma survivors Network that's one
of our programs and within that space um
I have come to know the limb loss
Community quite well and limb limb loss
is not always because of trauma trauma
is one of the reasons why it can be
because of a A congenital defect and it
can because be because of cancer but
these are folks who have suffered limb
loss and they are in need of a
prosthetic device or an orthotic device
and I have some folks with me from um
seos Prosthetics and Orthotics who are
going to talk about the differences
between those one is supportive and one
is actually a replacement for a limb so
that they can you know connect in their
community be active work you know
quality you know quality of their lives
and what we found out over time here in
New Hampshire is that we have been we
haven't been U you know we've been what
I consider not woefully U reimbursing on
the Medicaid side for this and
considering how this actually not just
impacts their lives but impacts the
communities that they live and work
within I think we have an opportunity
here to change this um so that's why I
bring this before you what we have um
been able to assess in now director
Litman is not here today um John
Williams from HHS told me that it was
completely okay for me to say that HHS
does support this bill um and what
director Litman was able to assess is
that we were at 80% of Medicare for
reimbursement and so what we did
considered is the incremental approach
which has seemed to work in this with
this kind of setting before and we're
thinking about moving our um our
Medicaid rate up so we're looking or the
ask here is to go from 80% to 90% to
cover uh the pro at that rate to cover
orthotic and prosthetic devices um so
that is that's that's basically why
we're here there is a manag care
contract um that has actually driven the
situation to where it is now that was
signed off on that pushed the price down
or the reimbursement down even further
so what this will do is by raising it
we'll be able to raising the base at the
Department of Health and Human Services
the Medicaid level coming from there
will actually be able to raise the
reimbursement on the Managed Care side
as well so I appreciate the opportunity
I think this is import this is very
important for the limb loss community
and again I you know it's one of the you
know it's one of my passions in my work
that I do here and the you know the New
Hampshire legislature as well as in my
you know my career as a you know
paramedic traumacare professional so I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
may have and if I can't I'm sure from a
technical perspective the folks behind
me are really great at doing this repr
representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question
um if if reimbursement rates are low and
it prevents people from getting new and
effective equipment I'm I'm completely
empathic to that idea
however you know we hear regularly about
Medicaid rates being low so we can't get
dentists to join the dental program
because Medicaid rates are too low um
there's a mental health crisis including
the fact that we can't um the mental
health centers can't um compete to hire
people because primarily because
Medicaid rates are low and um they're
Medicaid dependent we had
a an a physician on this very committee
talk about earlier this morning about
how a lot of providers don't even build
Medicaid and they just do it um
that the bureaucratic demands were were
more than the reimbursement they got so
my question really
is shouldn't this be done across the
board for Medicaid rates um why would we
take one specific area and um make it
90% of Medicare which Medicare people
say Medicare is inadequate as well but
in any case why would we do this for one
particular area of reimburse rather than
across the board thank you for your
question U it you know it would be in in
the best set of circumstances I would be
sitting in front of you talking about um
you know durable medical equipment
therapies and modalities across the
board um the reality is that was you
know quite honestly was not I wasn't
approached across the board but what I
will share with you is that and I think
you already know this because you've
done work in this area is that last year
um we were able to raise rates um and
and you know I could speak to the
Emergency Medical Services side of this
but this was Workforce across the board
to BR get more folks into the workforce
so that we could have you know we had
services available and that it was not
it was worth it was worth the time and
it provided the access to build Medicaid
like we got it up to 100% And that's the
first time you know for Emergency
Medical Services for 17 years they were
at 38% of Medicaid and I remember
running an ambulance service when it it
really we some we were like should you
know what's going to H we we would Bill
and get a check back for like $5 um so I
think we have started to Trend with
recognition in that direction and we did
it in the workforce so giving you that
background I would love you know I would
like to look at this broader right now
this is the group that's come performing
that has this need um and so I'm willing
to advance this for them and this might
help us get a larger group involved and
have this discussion further thank you
follow so I'm not really sure about this
the the rate increases which I
think well started being very low but
they still the rate increases were
dramatic and are very positive thing did
they just
affect
um services that providers performed or
did they did those rate increases also
affect things like prosthetic devices
they didn't and medical equipment
services that were performed is my
understanding um I think that we would
probably be in a different place today
and not even having this conversation if
it was in the other direction um I
always think of it honestly if I may
like being holistically that it's all
one but the truth and reimbursement is
that it's not so that's a great question
thank you thank you very much you're
welcome representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking uh my question I'm kind of in
the same you know headp space as
representative Shapiro but um one of the
things is that 80% already is a higher
rate than is being reimbursed in other
areas so maybe historically you could
just kind of tell us what are some of
the things that have led to us being
reimbursed at 80% as opposed to other
areas um and and why we already at a
high right there and I'm just curious to
know why that is thank you for your
question representative McAn oh so I
think 100% is actually where we want to
be in the end but I in respect to your
question I think the best thing for me
to do is let the folks from the orthotic
and prosthetic Community they can
address the the history I think which
would be really drilled down for you
okay In
fairness other questions sorry I
shouldn't be tapping my hands it's been
a long day seeing no questions no other
questions so okay thank you thank you
chair thank you everyone it's always
good to be here
also signed up to speak is Samantha
Toria from New Hampshire
Prosthetics have you asked for five
minutes if you could keep it closer to
three or so it' be better yeah thank
you uh my name is Samantha torus uh
thank you for allowing me to be here I
am the practice manager at seos
Prosthetics uh we're a local uh locally
owned an ampute owned uh prosthetic and
orthotic provider in the SE Coast New
Hampshire area we also service areas
around um the seos including Maine
Massachusetts and out even as far as
Raymond eping um I know you had some
questions about payments I hope I can
clarify some of that for you so our
reimbursements are really not at 80% of
Medicare I would say they're about 30 to
40% below the current Medicare rate
which I know Medicare is increased the
past few years which has been great um
unfortunately the Medicaid
reimbursements have not increased since
July of 2021 for Prosthetics and
Orthotics and durable medical
equipment um our fees are considered
bundled payments so they include
appointments they include the device
cost typically our orthotic patients are
seen for a minimum of about two visits
um our prosthetic patients can be seen
anywhere from 8 to 10 visits and these
visits are about half an hour to an hour
long um so I just want to also note that
we have about 800 Medicaid patients uh
as part of our database and patients
that we see
um to kind of just explain it plainly um
one of our knee braces that we provide
that cost us
$568 uh MediCare reimburses at
$958 again this includes device cost and
appointment fee
the New Hampshire Medicaid reimburses at
$524 and that means the Managed Care
organizations who are about 20% below
that uh they reimburse at
$419 so right there when we see a
Medicaid patient we can't cover the cost
of the device to see them and we're not
being paid for the services
provided so it's my hope that this
committee will appreciate the value that
we bring to our community in trying to
get get them back moving and on their
feet and I hope that you'll consider
increasing the reimbursements for us so
thank you thank you I can take any
questions if you need uh representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um my introduction in
New Hampshire was I was the medical
director at Easter Seals and we ran an
onp Clinic back in the Glory Days when
we were converting from metal to plastic
which was an awesome time because we got
to be very creative um I in discussion
that I've had with other people I think
it's really important and maybe you're
follow you're going to speak too yeah to
talk about what Orthotics actually is
because um you know it's not just an
off-the-shelf thing you do fabricate
there correct yes yeah and actually um
both Chris and Chris behind me they're
co-owners um they're practitioners
they're making the devices so um devices
for Orthotics can range from foot
Orthotics into your shoes all the way up
to neck braces back braces knee braces
um and they are custom fit and um
customized for the patient that we see
and there's a lot of time that goes
involved am I correct there is y so when
you talked about hours or I'm sorry can
I follow up um when you talked about
hours before that's just face Toof face
hours you're not talking about
fabrication hours as well correct and
you fabri oh sorry never mind okay
representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman so if I heard you
correctly you used one example of a
device that that cost you mhm like $500
and something dollars but you only got
reimbursed by
Medicaid
524 and then you got reimbursed by
Medicaid for 400 and something the
Managed Care organizations and that did
not and you didn't get any further
reimbursement for the hours you spent
actually meeting with the people for
whatever diagnosis or
um kind of developing the plan to so
I'm just curious how your business
survives that I mean how do you what do
you do do you not do you not provide
services to Medicaid patients do you do
it and take a loss we do it we take a
loss and it's getting harder every year
because the cost of goods is going up um
you know maybe five years ago it wasn't
as bad um postco world our supply chain
is crazy and the cost of goods has gone
up quite a bit and it is really hard and
that's why we reached out to sener
Apprentice for that followup followup
does that result in any way in raising
the costs for other people who maybe
have private insurance or paying out of
pocket because you have to you have to
survive we're pretty set with the
contracts that we have we get reimbursed
based on what we've agreed to with those
separate um commercial insurances so we
really don't have a chance to overbill
anyone our coding structure is very
strict about that so thank you
representative Weber did you have your
hand up uh no my question I did but my
question could answer to thank you
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
thanks again for taking my another
question does this also include like
wheelchair seating orthoses and things
like that as well or it doesn't we're
strictly Prosthetics and
Orthotics if this bill pass can I ask a
follow if the bill pass would that in
include that for other vendors I'm not
entirely sure how they bill um our
coding is set by hick pit codes um I
think I'd have to do a little bit more
research just not in my wheelhouse for
that yeah other
questions representative mlan just super
quick so actually your testimony
answered a lot of my questions great um
but um just to kind of follow up on
representative Shapiro do you know what
the breakdown is in terms since you you
know you can't recover cost anyway
because it's kind of fixed across the
board um actually so I guess it's kind
of irrelevant in terms of who who is
private insurance versus um what's
Medicaid what is the what is the breakup
I guess it's kind of irrelevant to you
anyways isn't it yeah it doesn't so I
withdraw my
question other
questions saying none thank you thank
you very
much also signed up to speak is C
crossdale from seast
Prosthetics sorry did I call somebody
out of order or
no if you could give it to around three
minutes sir appreciate it absolutely
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen Mr
chairman um as one of the co-owners of
seos orthotics and prics I think the the
thing that's become critically important
for us is the not just the decreasing
reimbursement over the past few years
but the the simple fact that as we get
more and more Medicare patients quite a
lot of them have Medicaid as a secondary
payer uh and of course you know
traditionally Medicaid always paid that
20% co-pay for medb devices and of
course over the past few years that's
been literally zero we've been getting
nothing because obviously the um
Medicare 80% was 100% of Medicaid as it
was uh then rated so we get we we have
to just forego that 20% and with
increasing number of Medicare patients
going forward that's putting an extra
strain on the whole business um if I
could also answer one question I heard a
little earlier was uh how do we make up
the deficit we we really have no options
to make up the deficits we we have no
way to sort of set what we charge we
have no way to also negotiate with our
suppliers what we can pay for devices we
are a very small business um you know
pretty much dealing with some fairly
fine margins um the best thing we've
been able to do over the past few years
is to be extr extremely selective about
what components we can afford to buy to
provide to people but there does come a
point where you want to be very careful
you're not fitting a substandard part to
somebody especially you know in a
medical
environment um I think another thing I
would like to do is just indulge you for
a couple of minutes on just an anecdotal
story uh just to give an example um I
had a Gentleman Just this morning he's
um classic example he's he's one of many
examples he he just happened to be my
patient this morning um he had a very
severe Road accident many years ago
ended up losing his leg at the knee
level on the left side um during his um
you know early years he was able to be
fitted with the prosthesis he was able
to go back to work he was a single
father bringing up two daughters in
later years his mother got very very
seriously ill she was obviously in her
later years in life and so he had to
look after his mother and so he he
eventually had to give up work and was
relying on medication paid pretty much
for all his Provisions during the time
he was looking after his mother uh
during that time obviously he needed
plenty of prosthetic attention and he
would come to us and the the
reimbursement rates were were very
scarily low we really weren't able to do
much except just try to maintain what he
was doing for as long as possible just
keep him on his feet so he could keep
looking after his mom and his two
daughters and the hope that eventually
he he would go back to work um during
that period of time we we obviously did
have to take a loss uh because you know
Prosthetics is expensive and over the
past well year and a half we've seen
cost of goods increased by approximately
89% which has not been reflected in any
reimbursements um luckily we were able
to keep him going his his mother
eventually did die his daughters have
grown up and have moved on now um and
he's just a single guy living on his own
but because we're able to keep him on
his feet he did eventually go back to
work he works at a ski resort he's not
doing anything athletic he's 71 now but
he would prefer to work and so he now
works in the administrative offices for
the ski resort so he pays for his own
insurance he's been off Medicaid for
quite a while now and and so he's you
know a happy productive member of
society so ultimately he is saving money
to the state in the long term if he were
to be wheelchair bound he would be on
Medicaid add infin item so I think he's
a good example of the many patients we
see with those set of C IR
stances I think that's all I really want
to add to this if there's any questions
okay thank you any questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks again for taking my
question um whenever we watch TV and we
see like the um you know the um adapted
games and things like that we see some
really cool leg types um um I'm just
wondering if in this en in reimbursement
environment and I don't want to use the
word cut corner but I'm going to use it
do you have to cut Corners to use um
devices of lesser value for that
particular age group merely because of
the reimbursement that you
got um I also hate to use the word cut c
yeah I didn't mean the word but yeah um
basically compromise um yeah I mean we
there is some compromise involved I mean
basically for specific L code sets which
is how we both of these things there'll
be a range of things like knees or feet
or something like this and we can
usually pick the most suitable one out
of that range of feet uh that's
available but with uh reimbursements
levels the way they are now you know the
highest end of that range is is not
usually something we can we can offer we
can get something close and it would do
them for a while but it wouldn't be a
great long-term solution we just have to
hope that we can keep them going long
enough that we you know we can sustain
looking after them the best way we can
over the next few years I mean the thing
about you know Prosthetics is you know
that patient is with you for life either
yours or theirs so you know in in all
honesty you have you you don't want to
cut Corners because sooner or later
they're going to say you didn't give me
the best thing available and they'll
move on which is fair so we always have
to look after them the best we can but
it is a judgment as to exactly you know
how much quality componentry we can
include because they'll come a point
where we we just lose so much that as a
business we would cease to exist yeah
thanks other question questions
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking questions
I'm really optimistic about charitable
donations and things like that um there
was this one lady a few months ago I saw
in the news she lost all four limbs in
one day from like sepsis or something
and since then she's raised like
$300,000 through GoFundMe to pay for
like everything um do you have any
system like that set up where you could
either do you know charitable
crowdfunding donations for individuals
or just maybe your business in general
you you put out uh something like that
and you say look we're running about
just making up numbers here $100,000
shortfall every year if we could get
that you know you might have thousands
of people donating $5 a year and there
and next thing you know you're covered I
mean charity is so easy nowadays um what
are your thoughts on that thanks there
are definitely a lot of organizations
that do focus on just those things but
we as a business don't really try to get
involved in the charitable side of
things I think it's kind of a an Effy
road to go down because of you know
having to keep very tight um control
over where you allocate what money you
know um we we help the patients the best
we can by um you know we have even X
patients donating things that we can
often recycle but you know we're limited
by what we can do as a business as far
as getting involved with the
Charities um you know and again a lot of
our patients probably aren't you know
the most most exciting examples that
Charities want to get involved with some
of them have other co-morbidities
they're not going to lead exciting lives
their goal is to get to the grocery
store and back again without needing any
assistance uh and some of them do have
you know work that they want to maintain
um it's it's not you know we do know
Charities and we can put them in touch
with Charities but then we we cut off
from there we're not really getting
involved with the
Charities representative
pazo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh I don't know
this system so excuse me if it's a basic
question uh to part are you allowed to
deny or delay a client and uh uh are you
allowed to ask for a
COR
um I mean we can either deny treatment
all together or not but we we have to
have a good concrete reason to do that
um generally someone comes to us with no
insurance whatsoever we're going to work
pretty diligently to try and find them
some kind of funding whether it's maybe
through vote rehab or or or some charity
some something like this that we can we
can refer them to um so we have been
very lucky that we've never had to deny
treatment on cost grounds um but again
you know pragmatically speaking we we
just have to be cognizant of the fact
that we're going to take some something
of a hit on that
and we we have to try and minimize the
hit you know because unfortunately if we
were to try and do that for every single
patient we would have already been out
of business by now yeah the margins are
just too fine with Medicaid and you know
Medicaid patients are increasing so and
and as you know our practice manager
sort of explained when it comes to you
know dealing with Medicaid a lot more
patient patients are now being pushed
onto Medicaid Advantage Plans which
again are another 20% below Medicaid so
that point you are definitely paying
more just to order the device than
you're ever going to be reimbursed for
it and that doesn't include things like
shipping or warranties or follow-ups or
adjustments right there are multiple
appointments needed and at that stage
we've accepted the fact that pretty much
those are free by that
stage representative
naram thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question do you um service
veterans yes we do have a VA contracts
and we do serve as veterans okay and do
they pay better they they do I mean we
have a contract with the VA at the
moment that's about 5% less than
Medicare 5% less 5% they pay 100% of
whatever the the cost is okay thank you
very much other
questions see none thank you thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Christoph
uh Christopher phips and so you've asked
for 5 to 10 minutes if you could keep it
closer to three I'd really appreciate it
sure yeah thank you for uh for having us
here today so I'm Chris Phillips I'm a
the co-owner of seos Prosthetics I'm
also a congenital amputee from birth uh
so I grew up um my parents were lucky to
have good insurance and I was um you
know able to get grade care uh growing
up and then went into the industry to to
really try to help people like myself we
do a lot of children it's work through
the Monarch school which uh brings
students from all over the state to
Rochester uh they're severely uh
disabled we do a lot of bracing for for
those kids most of them are on some type
of managed Medicaid at least uh either
full Medicaid or secondary Medicaid to
their parents insurance to cover the you
know excess cost such as high
deductibles and things like that so I've
been doing this uh in New Hampshire for
about 20 years now um and certainly I've
owned a co-own this business business
for 10 years U with with Chris
crosdale and seems like in the last 5 to
six years every year we have a
discussion about whether we're going to
continue seeing Medicaid patients um and
I have people from Monarch school I have
my uh pediatric um physical therapists
you know every year asking me if we're
going to keep
going um and every year we look at the
numbers and we realize that we're
basically implementing the Medicaid
Program uh you know through our own
personal funding basically to keep
seeing these kids and seeing these
people that uh really need our
services
um and I I just feel like that there's
going to be a year pretty soon where
we're just not going to be able to do
that and I I do think that if you look
at the other o companies in the state
we're a pretty small group there's only
five or six of us in the state and we're
being taken over uh the smaller
companies uh are being taken over by
larger corporations and they're making
decisions not to take Medicaid so you'll
see and and we've you know honestly we
made the decision probably four or five
years ago to not take wellsense which
was one of the manage Medica AIDS
because of the bureaucracy to get
through pre-authorizations and oh um and
so we take New Hampshire Healthy
Families and then straight Medicaid and
um and with this this increase which is
still only 10% because remember the
managed cares are allowed to take a 20%
cut off of that 10% so right now they're
taking 40 plus percent off of of
Medicare but if we could get the extra
10% then it would only be a 30% decrease
which is still not great but it is a
little bit better um we had talked about
trying to pick up a contract with
wellsense again because a lot of the
children that we see you know have
wellsense instead of New Hampshire
Healthy Families so a goal would be to
you know continue to provide care for
these kids and for these folks that you
know have these other Medicaid it's not
just kids I see a lot of amputees that
have Medicaid as well
um but my concern is that uh you know if
if this funding isn't uh increased that
you know we're a small company we have
six
employees uh and at some point uh which
I think would be fairly soon we're going
to make that decision um you know to not
take Medicaid again or in going forward
so that's why we're here and that's why
we reached out to uh Senator apprentice
and thank you for that time thank you uh
representative Nagel and then
representative thank you Mr chair thanks
for taking my question thanks for all
you do I really appreciate that so um if
not you then where will these people
go right so I do believe that there's a
uh our competitors on the Sea Coast
there's only one so far it's Hangar
Prosthetics and I don't believe they
take medic at this time um so uh so they
would most likely go to if they were on
the Sea Coast they would have to go to
conquered uh we have other patients
where there's some services that we
don't
provide uh that that go up to Littleton
from the Sea Coast to see you know
certain providers so I do think you know
if there's only five or six of us in the
state and we're all in different
geographical
locations um
it's going to be a burden for those
people to
travel representative
Shapero thank you Mr chair so could you
explain a little bit um for me about the
distinct you said that you
take at least maybe two of the three
managed care companies and also straight
Medicaid so when someone's not on
Medicaid but they're not um enrolled
with one of the managed care companies
so could you explain to
me the distinction between when you
build the state directly for someone on
on straight Medicaid versus one of the
managed care companies and what's the
distinction in how much you get paid yes
so I might have to rely on Samantha but
but it's my understanding that you know
straight State Medicaid is
20% at currently is 20% below the
Medicare allowable so if we were
building you know know $100 they would
reimburse $80 and you know and it's how
it used to be before the managed cares
came we talked to someone directly in
the state we got prior authorization we
sent a bill and we got that contracted
rate which was you know certainly below
so right now if we're um seeing someone
with New Hampshire Healthy Families
we're doing a prior authorization uh so
we're talking to someone in another
state usually not sure um we're getting
a prioritization we're waiting we're
submitting documentation and then
they're going to approve that
hopefully and then we would get
reimbursed at least 40% below Medicare
so the current managed Medicaid is
allowed to Bild by the state 20% below
the State Medicaid level so that's 40%
below Medicaid
Medicare 40% that's where you get that
knee brace situation where we're getting
reimbursed
$60 less than the actual cost of the
device I've seen that patient two to
three times for 30 to 40 minutes each
time uh to evaluate to measure to then
fit the device uh or if it's a custom
made device then I'm seeing them to cast
I'm filling that with plaster or
scanning that in three uh 3D printing
and then I'm fabricating it by hand and
then I'm coming back and fitting it and
then we're seeing them usually for a
followup as well so
follow up follow up so I know that the
idea of having
um Medicaid be managed by these
companies is that it will be more
efficient
um and save money um but in your
situation you're taking a you you're
having more of a deficit from because
they're there so I'm I know you're a
small company and there only a few of
you so this is maybe an unrealistic
question but has there been any attempt
to kind of address this issue with
directly to DHHS to the to the
Department of Medicaid um or whatever
they're called um and and and what kind
of um feedback have you gotten yes so
Samantha and I had a um a meeting with
DHHS maybe two and a half years ago
sorry um and uh and we explained exactly
that situation we provided data we had
Excel spreadsheets showing all the
different coding we build all of the
reimbursements and all the time that we
estimated that each of those um device
fittings Incorporated from high high
level Prosthetics all the way down to
simple you know Foo Orthotics that go
into shoes um and it was all basically
all in a deficit and we explained you
know the managed cares were taking the
20% uh and they were very understanding
and very sympathetic and then we never
heard from them again so that's part of
the reason that we have reached out um
you know to U Senator Apprentice thank
you yeah Senator Nagel again thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
so when I was at Easter Seals we had a
it was a small vendor that had a shop on
site and um um this was 30 years ago so
we lost money on Medicaid period the way
we made money though was the wham bam
thank you ma'am quick off the shelf
Braes and um what I've observed over the
last 20 years is that a lot of non
orthotist non prosus people are actually
selling those things fitting those
things in my observation taking money
away from you correct is is that a real
thing that you're observing does that
affect your bottom line and your ability
to stay afloat
it it's it's a good question and it's
it's a catch22 because uh you know a lot
of these things are being fit in
Orthopedic offices which is you know and
we've kind of accepted that as a
profession that wrist splints and
aircast boots and things that you know
you break my my son broke his toe
yesterday so he's going to be in an
aircast boot tomorrow uh I'll try to fit
it but he could easily get that at an
orthopedic Physician's office um and so
we've really tried to differentiate
oursel as a profession to do more custom
fabricated devices so especially our
office and and some uh some OMP
facilities blend like all this DME
equipment as well and they have kind of
two separate entities in their under the
one roof but our practice you know
because I think Chris's background is a
prosthetist my background is an amput
and and wanting to do more custom
fabricated uh devices we haven't really
been
um too concerned about a lot of that uh
quick fit stuff but it it's certainly
when you look at knee bracing and a
little bit of the higher end things it
does take money out of out of the
business
but other questions representative Paz
off thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so sometimes we need
to consider effectiveness of uh
intervention and I wonder how effective
your devices because sometimes we spend
money on things that are not very
effective like the state uh was spending
still spending money to advertise covid
vaccine to stop the transmission of
covid virus but it doesn't stop so you
mentioned that there are some
alignments and followups with
prosthetics so if there's alignments it
means that uh it was not effective so uh
or was it effective so is what
what what
the yeah could you speak to the Quality
sure that's a great question so when we
see uh
amput um a lot of times they're walking
for the first time so basically we're
fitting a device uh customade device so
when you fit a socket to someone that's
missing a limb uh that limb is going to
change so it's not going to be the same
two weeks later so they might have a
different thrust to the way they walk
and so part
of I don't want to go down the whole
billing problem with o andp but because
you're paid on a lump sum for that
device all those follow-ups go with that
visit so for a brace like Samantha said
it might be two or three visits for a
follow-up they might have a a spot that
it rubs because it's custommade they
might have some volume fluctuation or
something like that and you might need
to heat or pad that device and that's
part of that original payment we're not
charging that again so in a pris it's
very common for someone to change the
way they walk as they get used to
something and so you would need to
realign it and that's part of that
followup and with prosthetic patients
you know like Samantha mentioned
sometimes we see people six seven times
during that period of
care uh you know as they're getting used
to that device and that's part of that
original
payment okay uh representative mlan
thank you Mr chair so just to follow up
on that then so she was saying that the
the hardware itself just the hardware
was $500 so your actual cost for the
whole deal then factoring all this in
you're getting reimbursed you said
$524 but what is your total cost you
know in terms of not just the hardware
but just to give me a feel for where
you're at right and and we thanks for
the question we'd be happy to send you
that that spreadsheet as well because
what that did was we broke down our
costs to basically what it costs for an
hour of my time including the overhead
of the office including Samantha
including our two front desk people
including the fabrication we tried to
narrow that down and and put a general
um you know cost to each 45 minute
interaction and I think we came up with
about a $200 an hour you know so if I'm
seeing some for 30 minutes that's an
extra $100 that would be added on so if
I saw them for fitting and I saw or
valuation and fitting so you're you're
talking about another1 to $150 of just
time on top of that cost of that device
yeah
follow that's like
seven
600 on top could be yes yeah other
questions okay thank you thank
you I just have to clarify uh Michael
Bradley you signed up for 290 5 I think
you I'm assuming you mean 495 is that
correct yes excuse me Mr chair 495 okay
yeah I'll call on you in a few minutes
um but um I have no one else signed up
to testify on 455 FN uh Christina could
you tell me how many I'm sorry to brag
you up here again on the blue
sheet when in favor okay thank you I
don't know how many signed up online but
uh obviously that's available if anyone
wants to find out I'm going to close the
public hearing on SB 455 FN at this
time sorry representative Shapiro thank
you Mr chair I I would just like to ask
that um questions that are irrelevant to
the bill that we're talking about um
specifically the reference to covid
vaccines um be reigned in um not only
are they not relevant to the bill we're
talking about but I think there's
you know I I I know there's difference
of opinion but many of us feel they're
grossly inacurate he did kind of shift
his question more to a more relevant
stage but I understand what you're
saying
um okay um again I'm closing the public
hearing on S SP 455 FN it is after 2:30
so we're going to open the public
hearing on S sp495 FN and recognize the
prime sponsor Senator Carson uh who's
not only uh the majority leader of the
Senate but my Senator so welcome Senator
harison good afternoon Mr chair good
afternoon Mr chairman and good afternoon
members of the House Health and Human
Services committee for the record my
name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure to represent Senate District 14
comprising the towns of Auburn London
Derry and Hudson and I have for your
consideration this afternoon Senate Bill
495 which is relative to certification
of Alcohol and Other Drug use uh drug
use treatment facilities
um I think we all know that our uh
substance use treatment system has grown
exponentially over the last decade
thanks to the hard work of many
thousands of individuals now receive
Treatment Services each day from dozens
of Provider
organizations we want to believe that
all of our treatment providers offers
offers the best quality and the highest
quality Treatment available but many do
but quite frankly in fact
we really don't know for sure individual
practitioners are licensed as our
residential treatment facilities but the
fact is the vast majority of Outpatient
Treatment organizations do not register
with the state in any way because of
this lack of oversight we don't know who
these treatment organizations are or
where they operate and we surely can't
be sure that they all adhere to the best
practice and follow evidence-based
practices at A Min minimum this leads to
a wide range of quality of treatment
services available to individuals in
need at worst it can leave the door open
to abuse and misconduct by some of our
lesser treatment providers which can
weaken our entire treatment system and
aggravate the challenges facing some of
our most vulnerable friends family and
neighbors Senate Bill 495 looks to
address this lack of oversight and
strengthen patient protection in two
ways
first it would ask the Department of
Health and Human Services to develop a
certification system for our Outpatient
Treatment providers so the state has a
more comprehensive record of which
organizations are providing treatment in
our state and has a tool to ensure that
they are sticking to best practice and
providing patients with the services
they need secondly it would strengthen
lines of reporting misconduct by
establishing a new behavioral health
specialist position within
dhs's ombudsman's office dedicated to
specifically receiving investigating and
addressing allegations of
wrongdoing certainly the the current
ombudsman's office in within DHS does it
all and can address allegation but still
a culture of Silence exists within the
substance treatment world the behavioral
health specialist will be specially
trained and prepared to address the
unique challenges facing individuals
impacted by substance use disorder and
mental illness in the Senate we work
closely with Advocates and DHHS to amend
the bill in a way that makes it
impactful and workable for the
Department in its current form we
believe it will go far to lift up our
substance use treatment Network and
assure that individuals and Families in
Need have access to the highest quality
services it will help them in their
quest to achieve recovery from substance
use disorder and will go far to help our
state overcome the ongoing addiction
crisis Mr chairman at this point um I'm
going to conclude my testimony um and
thank you all for your time uh there are
people from the Department as well as
the treatment Community here who could
probably answer your questions much
better than I can so I really thank you
all for your time and the opportunity to
speak with you this afternoon okay thank
you Senator um so you you you don't want
to take any questions on you want to
defer to them I for some well some
reason I had a bill at 2 230 and 3 and
the one at two hasn't they were running
behind so I got to run back upstairs to
see if they've gotten one but again um
the treatment some members from the
treatment Community are here as well I
believe as the department and they could
probably answer your questions much
better than I could so thank you very
much Mr chairman thank you senator
also signed up to speak is Jenny O
Higgins from the Department of Health
and Human
Services good afternoon I'm Jenny O
Higgins I'm a senior policy Analyst at
DHHS for Behavioral Health um Senator
Carson was able able to cover very much
of my similar comments as she mentioned
we have worked closely with the Senate
committees in order to get the bill to a
place um where it it needs to be so in
its initial iteration there were a
couple of um specific technical
challenges that we have worked out
throughout that process and been able to
make sure that the bill will be workable
um we are looking forward to engaging
already in Ru making with some of the
treatment providers we've begun
conversations with them as mentioned
there is you know oversight of
individual clinicians through oplc um
and the um budman's office in its
current form um provides protection for
all those programs under DHHS however we
have you know 65 outpatient substance
use providers um registered with
Medicaid and of those we contract with
um only nine uh as the Bureau of drug
and alcohol services and so in its
original form this the part of the bill
that allows DHHS to do a certification
of those outpatient facilities
specifically tied it to if we have
funding with them and so that is a very
small number of those that we know to be
out in the community in existence so
this bill does allow the certification
broadly to look at all of the Outpatient
Treatment and look at its quality um and
be able to have that that certification
piece in place um and make sure that
we're not duplicating the efforts that
already exist under licens
happy to take any questions thank
you representative
Weber thank you for taking my question
because I'm really
bewildered um because as I
read what's in front of
me um I'm having a hard time
understanding where exactly it's
saying what we're doing
you said the stuff that this is in
addition to stuff that's already
licensed but if I look at the way it's
the bill is drafted on lines 8 through
11 uh what is already in statute is a
certification and licensing appears to
be new because it's what the the the
additional language is is or licensed by
so this is a new license and what I'm
having a hard time
understanding
is
um you know it's it's it says licensed
under rules adopted pursuant to 541a
well that's just the administrative
procedures act so that's Ru making but
it doesn't say where the requirement of
the license comes from and I assume that
the license should be coming from 172
colon 2A but but I'm just not
understanding how this licensing works
or exactly which kind of uh facilities
were talking about and I'm sorry for my
ignorance but I'm guessing that I've had
I have that problem maybe some other
people here do too absolutely thank you
for asking so your explanation would be
very helpful absolutely so in the
section that you're referring
to the lines 8 through 11 is talking
about the definition of a certified
substance abuse treatment facility so
what we're saying here is that
previously it had been defined including
funding in part or in whole by the
office of drug and abuse alcohol and
drug abuse really now known as the
Bureau of drug and alcohol abuse so the
um if you had that funding we could
certify you because only nine facilities
receive that funding and we know there
to be 65 that are just Medicaid enrolled
we don't know the landscape of those
that are not Medicaid enrolled and they
of those 65 there's over 100 locations
right so we know there to be a substance
use landscape for which we are unable to
certify so this bill would allow for us
to certify more broadly what we're
including in here is not um a new
license why we added or licens means
that the certification that we're
looking to add here for outpatient Would
Not Duplicate those facilities that are
already licensed under 151 so that's the
the rule making is of our licensing unit
is 151 and that it would include
residential substance use treatment so
residential substance use treatment
already has that oversight certification
would be for the outpatient and by
definition we're saying that both would
be considered if if you're licensed
you're exempt from certification but
talking about across our substance use
um treatment
Continuum we would be talking about them
as licensed or certified because this
allows you to have to not have to get a
certification if you're already licensed
under a residential rules so follow what
could I ask why my why it doesn't say
that I mean it would be very helpful to
me if it actually said and I'm not
trying to make things more complicated
and maybe I'm just being
particularly thick about a process that
I I just don't understand but um
I'm still very literally looking at the
words that are on the page and you use a
different vocabulary when you're
explaining it to me um this is adding
the licensing language to just the
definitional piece but on page two line
two you'll see that it says that those
that are that you wouldn't need a
certification includes facilities liced
under RSA
151 okay thank you and why is that
language not also
included upfront in in in the
definitional part when you go and
reference and it not that it can't be if
that would clarify this issue but when
you look at where we use the terminology
of certified substance abuse treatment
facility throughout the rest of the RSA
we thought that the definition needed to
be inclusive of those that are licensed
because they also already have the
additional oversite okay so the
definitional change is just including
that if you are certified or licensed
you are cons Ed a certified substance
beuse treatment facility okay
essentially you would be considered
certified by having a license right so
that those certification and licensure
would be okay thank you very much and
thank you for walking me through that
absolutely representative kofalt would
you have your hand up thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so
um do you have statistics showing sort
of the the the problem with the current
system so we've heard several mention
of patient safety or the need for
scientific
approaches um what's wrong with the
current system and do you have
statistics that can support that
assertion I think that you'll hear more
about the gaps in oversight from our
Advocates and treatment providers that
are here to speak to that today because
DHHS does not currently have oversight
of those facilities we would not be
receiving complaints
so you would not be receiving complaints
about them is what you're saying we
don't have any oversight over the
outpatient facilities except for those
whom with we con we we fund okay today
and so we would not have the information
about those gaps in Services okay this
is meant to correct that thank you um
so if there are if if the goal is
to get oversight of services that you
are not
currently um
funding how far does this reach and I I
I sort of read the definition of a
facility and it it feels like a circular
definition so um is the local AA group
that meets in the church basement now
required to be certified by DHHS is a
local church group or or church facility
that's providing some kind of um um
services for people with substance abuse
problems going now subject to DHHS um
oversight so this is for clinical
treatment so what you've described I
would I would call recovery
supports so this treat this would be for
clinical treatment under substance
substance use disorder treatment for
outpatient so it would include
outpatient facilities uh intensive
outpatient facilities and partial
hospitalization programs those levels of
care defined by the ASM criteria area
that are not residential and the reason
not residential is because they're
already
licensed uh representative Shapero and
then representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking this question um on page 2
line 20 it says the commissioner May
accept gifts grants donations and other
funding for from any source and shall
deposit those all such Revenue received
into the fund to do these
certifications do I take that to mean
that this program of certifying
these
um these Services is going to be reliant
on
donations I believe that that is
standard language for the creation of a
fund I would have to ask our finance
director but that is Who provided the
language for the fund and so I believe
that this is standard language for when
we create a fund in our statute and I'm
happy to go back and make sure I have
that answer correct but the um fees
would help to pay for the certification
longer term we would need staff to
implement this which is why the bill
does call out you know with sufficient
funding that we would be able to
implement
certification thank you followup follow
um yes I would appreciate that makes
sense to me if it's just standard
language but I would I would be
interested in learning about that um the
other thing question I have is um the
position of the
Ombudsman I wonder how that would be
integrated with the oversight by
licensing boards
so if you got a complaint about a
particular
organization and the clinicians who are
working in that organization but maybe
they're licensed social workers or
licensed substance Mis
clinicians how would
the um boards at oplc and the
Ombudsman office work together or would
they yes our current licensing and udman
offices do already interact with
oversight boards so they there is a
relationship that's already established
this this position is just added to our
existing Ombudsman so they would
continue to follow best practices as
they do today but it would the position
would have some expertise or training
specific to the behavioral health field
so they would share
information wherever legally possible or
where necessary yes is representative uh
Merchant sorry
okay thank you M sigin for taking the
question I understand the facility but
that's really kind of a building um so
the facility doesn't really provide the
services clinicians but don't clinicians
because of license have boards that are
responsible to so isn't there some level
of oversight today that oversees the
clinicians not the facility but the
clinical staff in that facility would
they not have some sort of supervision
or I understanding there's no
supervision by respective licensing
boards no they do the existing state
regulations through oplc um and through
our licensing you know units do help to
protect individuals um and to monitor
that of care for the clinician and then
the piece that licensing our our current
licensing would look at the facilities
and safety and quality of services and
then the the clinicians are still held
to the standards from the oplc so we do
have this in existing law but we don't
have the oversight for just outpatient
so we're looking to mimic some of the
oversight that exists for
residential follow thank you Mr chair so
that I'm clear
this is looking to like if you go into a
hospital my understanding with the
hospitals you're looking at the hospital
facility it's a facility oversite not so
much the clinicians in the facility so
therefore you're looking to be sure it
it's clean it's safe and and so forth
that's more of a building certification
than it is the clinicians I want to be
clear that we're talking about the
facility not per se the clinicians
because they're actually being overseen
by the respective licensing board it it
does include in the same in I mean M
much of the details will be um worked
out through the ru making process but
the idea theoretically is to have to
look in many ways at RSA 151 in the way
that we license residential and so it
would not be individual clinicians
there's carve out specific for hospitals
specifically for those that are are
already licensed through residential um
and Facilities that you know already
have those kinds of oversight our
community mental health system things
like that so this is for a practice of
clinicians and where they're where
they're seeing
clients Senator Weber thank you for your
patience sorry about that that's quite
all right um they're they're all good
questions so
um what I'm trying to understand and my
first question comes off of the uh
question from representative
Shapiro uh if I'm looking
on the first page line
26 uh and again it's the subject to
available funding the the commissioner
shall establish personent who
rules um the rules that this is going to
operate under so if there's no funding
not only will will there not there won't
be rules and there won't be
certification unless there is funding
forthcoming in some way that we have not
yet defined is that correct yes so
initially the you know we've looked at
this bill in a couple different
iterations and it does require staff for
us to then do the certification however
we believe that in its current form this
bill does allow us to begin the rulem
process without adoption of the rules
until those positions are in place
through the budget year but it allows us
to begin to work with stakeholders and
with treatment providers to write the
rules so that we can figure out some of
the real detail work of what the certif
ification should include and work with
oplc and many of the the licensing unit
many of the questions you're asking
today it's can we get in the weeds to do
that work that may take quite a while
and then look at um how to budget for
positions that could do the
certification okay that's that's making
much more sense to me thank you very
much for that so the actual positions
would then come in the next budget cycle
so that one would
hope right got it but you but you would
have a leg up on being prepared and
knowing the scope of what those
positions are and what would be needed
so if I may have a second completely
non-related non-follow-up question we
were talking also about the licensing
for the folks who actually provide the
services which you're doing through oplc
and I'm noticing on page three on page
29 and page 30 the complete
repeal of the the definition of
certified alcohol and drug abuse
counselor and relative to the definition
of a designated drug counselor and I
haven't looked up those actual statutory
sections but are we are we completely
doing away with those particular
licenses and if
so with what are we replacing them
so we're just we just simply don't call
them that anymore and so the language is
Antiquated and so we could replace the
language in this RSA with that as that
is mimics oplc and what the current real
lure is okay so there are other things
that supersede that and we're just
getting rid of the archaic language
exactly okay thank you very
much other questions representa
representative South
King thank you Mr chair I have two
questions about this um my first one is
on um page one uh line 8 um to piggy
back a little bit on something that was
brought up earlier
um there's two types of you know
institutions ones that take government
money and then ones that don't and in my
understanding this correctly that this
is going to allow those who don't want
to take government money just you know
private organizations from now being
labeled as certified substance abuse
treatment facilities this is going to
have greater buy in for them they yes
you would be as a private entity would
under this be need to be required to be
certified to practice in New
Hampshire right well it's it's it's
actually I don't know I feel like it's a
little bit little bit more than that
because now it's basically it's getting
it's striking out that part saying that
it's funded in part by or in whole so
it's just allowing more facilities to be
labeled um they can operate today in New
Hampshire with no oversight so this
allows the department to certify those
agencies that do or do not receive state
funding okay um and then my second
question is on page three Roman numeral
uh Roman numeral 2 um um it it basically
also sounds
like it is a takeover right because
you're going to have two types of
Institutions let's just say some that
are Orthodox and some that are
unorthodox maybe the unorthodox ones are
religious based or some other way I
can't even think of right now but
there's different ways of skinning this
cat so to speak and it sounds like in
order to be able to even continue doing
that they're going to have to become
orthodox
um do you see it that
way I do not because this is clinical
treatment and so there is a practice
that needs that to in order to have a
high quality of care they just like
every other type of Health Care should
make sure that that quality is high and
so therefore I think they would fall
within the the rules as written in terms
of the way that we currently license
facilities and then our certification
rules would mimic you criteria set forth
by the the federal accreditations and um
operations under that ASM criteria so I
think it would be asking folks to come
up to an appropriate clinical standard
to make sure that people get the care
that they
deserve I don't know I just I don't
fully I guess I'm struggling to wrap my
head around it because you've got you if
they're not taking any government money
um and they currently exist there's
currently that system going I don't know
it just seems weird to me that all of a
sudden now they'd have to become more
Orthodox I don't know I'll have to think
about it later I think it's it's um if
you think about it in terms of of
physical health care that there's
there's not an orthodox and unorthodox
like ways to practice medicine right so
it's become making sure that there is
that that there's a a standard of
quality I'm not sure I agree with that
but thank you representative
McKay your microphone's off thank you Mr
chairman um do you have any information
about uh people who have been badly
treated or inappropriately treated or
unscientifically treated I I take it
that the purpose of this is to not have
people be treated by
inappropriate U professions that
clinicians I was a licensed clinical
social worker the licensing board is
very
strict and that they often will uh
penalize and take away the license of
individuals do you have any
information about people who have been
badly treated there must be some
motivation to get this started and I
wonder if there's
information about how many of our
citizens have been
inappropriately
treated and what happened to those
clinicians who did
that so this is an issue Across the
Nation it's not specific to New
Hampshire but and it is specific to New
Hampshire right but um but substance use
treatment has um long has had a long
history of very little oversight and so
a very vulnerable population has been
taken advantage of in a number of ways I
do think you'll again hear more of those
examples from some of our treatment
providers and advocacy agencies that are
here today but because the department is
not currently overseeing that outpatient
um I do not have those examples do you
know follow up follow up do you know who
would have that information I think
you'll have you know Jake Barry
testifying here today that could speak
to uh why new Futures you know was
working toing bring forward this Bill
thank you representative Missour yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and it was actually a
question I had before uh representative
King brought up what he did but on page
three uh lines 10 through 11 where it
says no person may establish maintain
operate or conduct any program or
facility for substance use treatment dot
dot dot but I kept hearing you say
before that this is specific to clinical
treatment but those that doesn't say
that to me for substance use treatment
that's very Broad and more encompassing
to me than just clinical treatment so
this is that this what I'm struggling
with similar to what representative King
said that that limits a whole
area of of people that help with
substance abuse that are not
clinically you know they regulated so
people that I I believe and I'm just
trying to make an assumption to get to
the best answer but correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe the what you're
talking about um was also based on an
earlier question around recovery
supports like AA and Na and smart
recovery and things like that our
recovery Community organizations
faith-based programs um our recovery
supports that are a critical part of the
Continuum of Care and are not considered
treatment
representative
Weber so again to try and tease out a
little more of this am I right in
thinking that right now I could put a
sign out at the bottom of my driveway
that says
Lucy's ice waterer bath substance abuse
treatment I don't have any knowledge
about whether ice water baths are
helpful or not but I could put a sign
out and because bathing people in ice
water is something that I don't have to
have a certificate for of any sort I
could just ask people for money
particularly desperate people who are
desperately looking for a solution and
say come to me and have ice water baths
because I think that's good for you and
there's no regulation now and that's why
we need this is that a far-fetched but
possible scenario or I know we have seen
this in other completely unregulated
areas and
so I'm I'm wondering if if if there are
examples that could be that extreme so
now yeah I'm not sure if I can answer
your question I think what we're looking
to do with the bill and maybe we can
clarify it and that's something that
needs to be worked out in a future
iteration but the idea is to oversee
those outpatient substance use treatment
facilities that are already um fall
within that ASM criteria and the levels
of care that are a part of of clinical
treatment so my example would be outside
even of that yes okay thank you
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for answering all
these detailed questions I have another
one for you can you let me know what
part of the statutes protect um
Alcoholics Anonymous and from other
things like this from being impacted
from this I know I'm hearing this from
you right now but when we get to the
rules process and we get to Jael car if
you come in with something that ends up
including Alcoholics Anonymous but
that's not in the statutes anywhere we
can't object to it for that reason in
Jael car and I'd like to know what
protections there are because that may
be fine this time in rules but I don't
know what happens next time it's updated
and if we were to hurt AA I I wouldn't
be able to forgive
myself um okay thank you for your
question I'm I'm sorry I'm trying to
answer on the Fly and so bear with me
while I think through this but on um
actually um could you just get back to
us with that answer I'm have a feeling
we're probably not going to exec this
one today and I would like to know
specifically where in the statutes will
protect it because uh we don't want us
to get into trouble just guessing we do
though I I will absolutely work out a
better answer for you but I also just
have a one- sentence answer to give you
which is page one line 29 begins to say
that those um providing early
intervention treatment Outpatient
Treatment intensive Outpatient Treatment
and partial hospitalization residential
medically managed intensive treatment
which are all um levels of care under
Asam criteria and so that I do think we
get a little bit more specific into who
can be certified and I think we'd be you
know happy to work with you to make sure
that it's very
clear and I'm also going to consider
your question and try to get you a more
thorough answer thank you thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr
chair I want to go back to page three
lines 23 through
27 and be clear
that what you're looking to
investigate is not so much the clinical
staff but in a facility you could have
non-clinical staff and therefore that
could be causing an issue for an
individual but I want to be clear at
least I'm trying to understand it to be
clear that that if it's a clinician
that's causing the issue it should be
then referred back to the appropriate
licensing board for them to take the
action against the license C and not get
into a situation where this is saying I
have an omnius who's investigated
certain things and I think the clinician
should be taken care of I'm going to
take action against the clinician which
is totally separate and outside of the
domain in my opinion of the licensing
board so help me understand how do I
unravel all that because in this case
you got something that's saying hey
authority to go in
there and do something under the rules
which could impact the clinician but
they're also trying to follow the
licensing board so how do I unravel that
yes I can get back to you with more
details on that answer as well but the
current the on budsman positions and
oplc and lure are all already existing
and so that piece I know is already
figured out so the detailed answer
should you know come from another one of
our DHHS staff members um and but this
is the certification piece and that this
um budsman position in those lines that
you're referencing is to add a position
into our existing um budsman they would
still fall under the way that they
currently operate to work with the
certification board with when
appropriate and you'll also hear more
from The Advocates of the reason that
they brought forward the bill which
includes a a specific type of example
that you have brought forward which is
harm potentially done by someone who is
not a
clinician follow up follow up and the
other question I have goes back to what
been brought up a couple of times under
page 3 10- 12 no person which I assume
if I'm a solo practitioner who wants to
provide substance treatment I have to go
through the owner's process of getting
certification that's following up on
what sort of represent Weber is talking
about but if I have their credentials
and I want to hang a shingle out I have
to go to certification I just can't go
out and hang out my shingle I have to go
back to
DHHS get a license and if I do the math
correctly it's going to cost between 5
and $110,000 because it's number of
people to raise
$342,000 that's not a small amount of
money for somebody's trying to do
something for the benefit of society as
a so practitioner individual clinicians
would be exempt where does it say
that not sure can search but it is has
been discussed multiple times so thank
you
what I'm Mr what I'm trying to be
fearful of is that you don't have what I
call Corporate America
becoming the the vehicle because they
can afford to have them pay the $5 or
$10,000 which is going to then take a
lot of individual clinicians that want
to do something on that behalf and then
forcing them out of the market because
they can't afford it
economically
yep okay did you find it or no I I have
a list of questions that I can get back
to the committee with those detailed
answers and also there may be somebody
behind me that has found it more quickly
than me just a challenge to do in real
time other questions
for person representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for one
last question um I may have missed this
but is there a reason why we're striking
everything from the office of alcohol
and drug abuse
prevention because we're striking all
the references to that that I can see
I if you don't know that's a valid
answer yeah and it doesn't exist that's
just not a there there is not an office
of alcohol and drug abuse prevention so
it may be that we need to replace it but
it's
the removing it because it doesn't exist
is a great reason okay so thank
you any other
questions okay I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Jake
Barry from new
futes okay I'm stepping in the hot seat
good afternoon my name is Jake Barry I'm
the vice president of policy at new
Futures as many of you know new future
is a nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy
and advocacy organization we've been
working for more than 25 years to help
address substance use and addiction in
our state uh I don't want to repeat too
much of what's been said this afternoon
but I do want to stress our strong
support for this bill in addition uh
though they're unable to be here this
afternoon I do because they're off
supporting patients I do want to mention
the strong support that exists across
the Healthcare Community of our state uh
in addition to my own written testimony
I've shared with you a joint letter of
support from more than 30 substance use
mental health health care and other
provider advocacy and funding
organizations in nearly nine months have
been working on discussing this Bill
I've not heard anyone speak uh speak
against it conversely everyone uh from
the provider Community the recovery
Community elsewhere uh have recognize
the need to strengthen oversight and
enhance patient protections within our
substance use treatment system um a few
matters that I want to touch on the
questions that were raised to M Mr
Higgins uh the the need for this bill
came around so for years uh anecdotally
we have heard uh uh reports of uh uh
group counseling session that don't that
aren't abiding by proper uh patient
provider ratios we are hearing you know
we hear anecdotally about uh providers
who are uh uh you know in place who are
not um properly certified who are not uh
uh Advanced enough in their own recovery
uh all of the you and most recently we
heard um last spring from a podcast that
I'm sure many of you saw from New
Hampshire Public Radio called The 13th
Step which detailed uh a a a a system of
uh sexual assaults a series of sexual
assaults uh within one of our largest
substance use treatment systems uh there
there's a gap in our oversight here as
as has been noted uh individual
practitioners are licensed residential
facilities are licensed uh but when it
comes to outpatient treatment providers
uh if there are folks who do not
contract with the state they are not
registered with the state we don't know
where they are many in most cases we
don't know where they are we don't know
where uh what kind of treatment they're
providing we certainly can't sure that
they are Opera operating uh uh following
uh best practice following
evidence-based standards and providing
the highest level of care for these
people in our community who need it who
need it most this not only impacts the
recovery of these individuals uh but it
weighs down it depletes our entire
substance use treatment system this is a
system that we have built to be very
much interconnected but when folks are
being are not receiving the quality of
treatment they need uh they are
individually harmed but they it impacts
their abil their their ability to
achieve maintain recovery which means
that they they may be at higher risk for
relapse and may end up back in the
system back in the treatment uh having
suffered more harm uh to have to be you
know added on to their their original
exposure this is a system that we have
spent years to build that we have spent
millions and millions of dollars to
construct and we continue to fund
through millions of dollars in state and
federal funding uh and yet these gaps in
oversight um again weigh it down deplete
it they they uh limit the abil ility of
our best treatment providers to provide
the the services that that needed that
we need to uh to to help all of our
individuals and to help our state
overall as a whole overcome um the the
addiction crisis uh so this is intended
to fill that Gap uh to ensure that um uh
all of our treatment providers that that
there is just a more complete map uh of
who is providing services in our state
uh and and what quality of services
they're providing and to ensure uh for
the udman piece that there is a
mechanism to to really respond to and
investigate incidents of of misconduct
when they are reported um this would add
Again The Specialist position with with
the EMB busman's office that would be
specially trained and equipped to
address to address the very unique uh uh
conditions that uh uh in concerns
surrounding the vulnerable individuals
who are looking to recover from uh from
substance use disorder um so I hope that
gives a little bit of background uh
again we we feel very strongly about
this bill
uh all of the recovery centers I know
there's talk about the recovery
Community all the recovery centers in
the state support this uh the New
Hampshire providers Association which
repres you bet there's broad support for
this bill there's a recognition of the
urgent need to to again fill these gaps
and I'm happy to take questions thank
you representative of Seth King thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
questions um in your own words can you
tell me um what the difference is
between certification and
license honestly in uh my view the
biggest difference is that um lure is
not currently applied to uh again a
segment of service providers in our
state of of outpatient service providers
they are not subject to lure licensure
requirements uh so this uh you know
ultimately I think these systems would
be very similar very parallel um but
they uh but the biggest difference is
that it only applies to a segment of the
service provider organization followup
followup because in my mind I see a
certification as sort of like a stamp of
approval but um you could still exist
without that stamp of approval whereas
with licenser you can't do it at all
unless you've got the license
and as was noted earlier uh it says
programs and
Facilities uh required to be certified
shall include for example early
intervention treatment so um you're
going to be required to get this
certification uh and then later on it
says
um no person may establish dot dot dot
without the certification so to me that
just seems like lure it's not it's
beyond certification at this point if
you're not even allowed to do anything
without the certification then it's it's
it's a license why why even bother using
the word certification because it it
sort of I don't know I feel like it it
kind of dupes us into being like Oh yeah
certification is a good idea and then
it's like no this is a license we're
talking about you can't do it without
you can't do it you can't even do early
intervention without without basically a
license now how does that make any sense
again early intervention is part of the
again the spectrum of services that are
part of the the the you know again Asam
support Ser Asam defining Services right
and and so the I mean this is not
intended to mislead in any way uh this
is intended to uh you know there there
are defin issue definitional issues if
we call this lure because there is
already an exist an existing lure
requirement that applies by the way not
only to Residential Treatment programs
but to residential Healthcare programs
across the across the Spectrum so should
we try to call this lure uh that would
create all kinds of of confusion and and
and uh and lack of clarity this is
intended uh you know again I think there
will be many parallels between a
certification and lure requirements uh
this is in intended to ensure that there
is a minimum level of care that is being
adhered to by all of our service
providers uh um and again these are are
uh you know substance use treatment is a
it's a it's a medicine it's a science
there are establish minimum levels of
care we just want to make sure that they
can be applied to u to all of our
treatment providers across the board
again with exemptions for small
independent uh small independent
practitioners because they are already
covered by individual lure uh and and
other um other areas as needed
representative Shapiro and then
representative Merchant then
representative to thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking this question
would I be right to be um reading on
page
to line to
um that the answer to earlier questions
about independent sole
practitioners um where it says
independent
providers etc etc etc shall be exempt
from certification correct sir that's
that's the intention to establish that
again single shingle folks as we call
them are are not to be subject to this
that is not the intention this is for
larger provider organization knowing
that again individual practition are
also covered by professional lure so
that's page two line two correct thank
you representative Merchant then
representative kofalt thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr Barry for being here and
taking my question I totally support the
intent of the bill I'm just wrestling
with some of the detail with it of
course and one of the things I keep
hearing is the word service provider and
I'll go back to I mentioned before a
facility does not provide a service
clinicians do sure so therefore the
issue is
clinicians operating outside of their
lure are doing things that are
not
appropriate shouldn't the appropriate
place to be is go to the licensing board
for that clinician versus the facility
because the facility Le doesn't have a
lot of
um you hold the administrator
responsible when they weren't the one
doing the service thank you for the
question how me untangle that because
that's what I'm wrestling with so no
thank you for the question
representative know it's very good and
apt question question um what we what we
have seen in her this is again anecdotal
because there is no oversight mechanism
to be able to track again who these
pract you know who these uh
organizations are or where they operate
so it's very difficult for us to compile
compile data on this right we're trying
to fill that Gap uh what we hear
anecdotally is of certain uh uh provider
organizations where this is part of the
culture where it's not just a single
practitioner who is stepping outside the
lines but if that person were to leave
and lose their lenser they would be repl
by somebody who might do something very
similar because this is part of the
organiz organizational culture so the
intent here is to build up again an
oversight mechanism uh uh to be able to
guard against that and ensure that it it
you know again we already have
mechanisms to stop individual
practitioners and and help to sort of
keep them in line we don't have that for
an organization uh in which many of
these organizations have multiple sites
and have you know many many
practitioners and yet again it is built
into the the part of the organizational
culture follow up follow up
so if the intent is to look at the
culture within an organization I hear I
think you're going if you someone's
reporting somewhere I guess it sounds
like there's no place for them to report
it but if you're getting a licensing
board that's getting multiple
inquiries from patients and therefore
multiple investigations shouldn't that
Bo to be taken some sort of action or
alerting someone I'm just trying to
understand where it's breaking down
because you have license clinicians out
there that are being held to a standard
by the licensing board so I'm just
trying to understand where this is
breaking down because they're the ones
ultimately should be held accountable I
I think um you know what we saw and what
we learned uh through the 13th Step last
year and again that that was dealing not
not just with the level of substance use
treatment was being provided but that
was dealing with again a series of of uh
sexual assault and misconduct
allegations right that that was coming
down from from the top from higher
higher level administrators um that sort
of set a culture but this was an
organization that that was um sort of
outside of the the again the oversight
and Reporting lines to some to some
extent and that there was not the
ability to hold number one these nonclin
these non-clinicians uh responsible um
but again I would I would argue that
even at the clinical level again we hear
that um you know there are some of these
these organizations that are not as
committed as we would like to to
providing the highest level service and
when in individual clinician um you know
these these concerns again when you're
talking about patient provider ratios
and so on it's not just a single
clinician this is across the
organization thank you representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so
um same question I asked the the the
last person um because I've heard you
used the I mean you you've advocated for
a science-based approach and
evidence-based
approach and yet you're making the case
for this bill you've used the word
anecdotal or anecdotally at least four
times I think five times and you're
referencing a podcast I'm which I'm you
know I I don't want to belittle events
that occurred but I'm I'm struggling
with um where is their actual data where
is there information to to to indicate
that there's an actual problem that we
need to solve so there's there's a
statement over and over again that we
need oversight I'm looking for where is
the problem that we're trying to solve
so what data do you have to indicate
that there is a problem that needs to be
solved um first off I mean I'm certain
nationally there there's well
established data about you know rates of
of um again misconduct and and abuse and
and sort of vulnerabilities within the
substance use system but as far as
Statewide you know Miss o Higgins
articulated well that um again without
any level of oversight we are unable to
track we are unable to monitor the you
know this this segment of the of the
provider population of these outpatient
providers specifically if they do not
contract with the state then we again we
don't have record of where they are of
who they're treating or so on um so you
know that's part of the intent of this
is to fill that Gap to make sure that we
are able to uh to to track and gather
data and information um so that you know
we can build in these protections
representative mlan thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so um there's there's a lot of
emphasis in in the testimony and the
discussion um about uh the Outpatient
Treatment providers but when the when
the prime sponsor brought forth the bill
you know she's talking about you know we
have a whole bunch of basically Guerilla
providers that are kind of kind of
operating a little bit under the radar
it was my impression that those were
most mostly in in the residential
treatment category um so maybe that's a
a misunderstanding that I have um so
could you maybe talk to that a little
bit where where are we seeing the bulk
of the problem is it you know on the
residential treatment side is it on the
outpatient side because this does seem
kind of broad to me and especially
you're getting into a lot of the
outpatient stuff so um I just like to
maybe go back to where we really seeing
the problem and you know because this is
very broad thanks sure and first off
again I want to reiterate that this bill
is uh you know restricted to clinical
outpatient services which cover a
traditional outpatient intensive
outpatient and partial hospitalization
those are really the three classes of
services that we're trying to capture
here because they are not captured
elsewhere uh I think Miss o Higgins
mentioned that uh there are and pardon
me I forget the number 63 60 you know
more than 60 providers outpatient
providers who are register who take
Medicaid in the state of those D DHHS or
the Bureau of drug and alcohol Services
contracts with nine of them of the rest
so that that leaves again this Gap in
oversight with the remaining 50 some odd
providers there and those are only the
ones who who register with Medicaid the
ones who did not accept medicate uh the
state has no record of them the state
has so so again if you want to ask how
many of them there are we don't know
we're unable to know if you're trying to
ask how many people do they treat we
don't know we're unable to know and if
you're looking to ask about you know
instances of of again abuse or
misconduct or the level of service they
provide we don't know we're not able to
know that's what this bill is intending
to
address follow up so yeah because I'm
just looking in on at the top of page
two it does talk about residential
treatment and so maybe I was being
confused as to where the problem was
really lying I I was thinking it was
more of a problem with residential proce
uh treatment facilities you're saying no
the bigger problem is on the outpatient
side that's where the lack of oversight
exists is where the outpatient decide
not having to do with residential yes
sir and so residential treatment is
already covered they're already licensed
they're already licensing standards that
exist and yes we're not touching that in
this Bill thank you representative Leon
did you have your hand up no any other
questions representative Nel thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question go I'm just curious so in in
the rehabilitation medicine world we
have a thing called carf which is
totally voluntary which kind of does
what you're talking about um it provides
you know you can voluntarily apply for
certification of your facility and you
know while it's not mandatory there's an
incredible Financial incentive to be
accredited because insurers will be
happy to work with you is there any
analogous type thing in the substance
abuse world and can you accomplish the
same thing you're trying to accomplish
here with more of a voluntary program um
to my knowledge there's not something
analogous within our state anyway it may
Exist Elsewhere um I that's certainly
something we could look into I would
certainly be fearful that the the Bad
actors again who are the ones we're
really trying to capture here would not
necessarily be eager to uh to achieve
voluntary certification uh and and again
those are the ones that we're trying to
capture here the ones who either
intentionally or unintentionally are not
are not following best practice or
evidence-based services and therefore
are weighing down the entire system
representative McKay and then
representative
Weber thank you Mr
chairman I think several people have
echoed what I said and that is what
exactly is the problem and I think now
you've done a pretty good job of saying
from your point of view what the problem
is and that is it's not
residential it is out
outpatient probably independent
outpatient uh my
concern is
um what happened in the past that uh and
I I think you made one reference to
sexual misbehavior in some
agency it's that kind of
information that I would would help me
to
understand what
happened I've been on a licensing board
and I it's very strict so that you're
not criticizing licensed board or
licensed
practitioners and those are not the ones
that are creating the problem so the
question is how do we get at those
individuals uh who are
practicing uh and perhaps legally under
the present law uh and is that the
purpose of this
legislation I so so yes certainly as you
said we're not we're not here in this
legislation trying to address individual
license sh we we we re you the licensing
boards do what want Wonder F job uh to
the extent that they're able to uh to
again provide supports and keep people
doing what they supposed to be doing
what we are concerned about is the
places where there may be again an
organizational culture uh that that
whether it's allowing sexual misconduct
to exist or or again not following um
best practice or evidence-based
standards when it comes to treatment
um that it expands Beyond in individual
clinician
uh it you know if again if somebody
loses their license and they're out the
door you'll follow somebody else may
come in who is facing additional
pressures to again not follow these best
standards um so that I mean that's what
we are trying to capture here uh again
and there are some there is a segment of
the outpatient provider popul of the
provider population that is not subject
to any standards or or lure requirements
within the state we are trying to close
that Gap make sure that everyone is
being um held to to some uh clinical
best practice and is being you know uh
um being monitored to ensure they're
providing the best Services possible to
support our entire system follow up
follow up can you be more precise as to
exactly what it is you're trying to do
because you're not talking about
changing licensing or or um
certifications and I agree
certifications I get uh emails almost
every week do you want to be CER ified
and this that or the other thing sure
and those certifications are useless
licensing is a very different
situation but it still seems as if
there's a gap
here because there there
are
significant uh problems in terms of the
number of professional mental health
people we have in the state and that's
across the board at social workers
psychologists nurses psychiatrists sure
across the
board what is this doing about getting
more people licensed because that's
where the protection seems to come
in so thank you with the question
representative and I should say my
organization and many of our partner
organizations who have worked on this
bill have worked for years to try and
support you know expanding the workforce
to meet the needs of our state we would
certainly not um support something that
we saw as interrupting that or or
harming uh our Treatment Community in
any way um what this is intended to do
is ensure that uh the Department of
Health and Human Services has the tools
that it needs to be able to ensure that
highlevel evidence-based treatment
services are being provided across the
board we already have those tools uh
mostly in the residential space we have
those tools for individual practitioners
we do not have those tools for outpa for
outpatient providers again there is a
lack of oversight a lack of uh ability
to know who is who is operating in the
state and what level of service they're
providing and we know that if there are
gaps in in the quality of services
provided across our Network that weakens
the entire system and we it cost us more
money to treat more people increases
human suffering uh and and it just is a
is a a cost on the entire
system one one more
followup um the
can you tell me on page
two where commissioner shall adopt the
rules and where in
there is the rule that does the things
that you want to
happen so the legislation was crafted uh
you know very intentionally uh to give
the the commissioner and DJJ the
authority to craft the rules and the
standards as they as you know they need
I um they in many ways are the experts
they they are they are working with the
treatment providers themselves uh to to
to do this uh so you know we did not
want to dictate what those rules and
those standards are we wanted there to
be a process of engage you know
stakeholder engagement to make sure that
we are are uh engaging the private Comm
the provider Community to establish
those rules so what this really does is
Kickstart a process that allow you know
that kickstarts the development of rules
and these standards uh uh so that
hopefully when we come back a year from
now and try and get some of these
positions funded in the budget There are
rules in place where they can go out
into the field and begin to again um uh
fill that Gap map out our our services
and ensure that the best practice is
being
enforced I'd like to be able to support
this I'm
struggling representative Weber I I
think perhaps I can help Focus the
inquiry that my colleague is um who has
a great deal
more techn techical knowledge about
licensing of professions than I do but
from all of our different levels of
knowledge in this committee what I'm
hearing you say and the people who spoke
before you say is oh this just applies
to outpatient services it doesn't apply
to residential treatment and if you read
the bill on page 20 on line
28 of P the first page it says programs
and
Facilities required to be certified
shall
include but not be limited to which is
why I think some of the people are
anxious about what else it might cover
so it says include but not be limited to
those providing early intervention
treatment outpatient treatment intensive
outpatient and partial hospitalization
treatment residential treatment which we
have been told repeatedly it doesn't
cover and medically managed intensive
treatment which is a lot of different
treatments and which doesn't include
everything because it says it
specifically it's not just limited to
these then there's a period which it
took me a while to find and on line two
of page two we start in by the people
who are exempt from these certifications
and that's great but I don't see and
maybe they're defined
elsewhere we've got five or six
different categories of treatment none
of which appear to be defined anywhere
all of which require to be certified and
and I
think I'm just speaking for myself but
when I listen I hear that other people
may be having the same kinds of
concerns um how do we know exactly what
those things are because it sounds
incredibly Broad and I don't have any
definitions
here first off thank you represent for
the question certainly I noted there is
a typo residential treatment is listed
here when it clearly should not be uh
that that's certainly something that can
addressed as far as the I think that
that remains from an earlier iteration
of the bill we will uh we will be sure
to address that as far as the
definitions I would certainly defer to
my friends at DHHS who know better than
I do but I'm certain that these that
these categories of of of treatment are
defined elsewhere in State Statute or
administrative rule um and and so they
were not specifically defined here
because they are I'm certain defined
elsewhere but again I would defer to my
colleagues in the department and a
followup to that but but this is a
statute and a statute can't be dependent
on a definition found somewhere in an
administrative rule uh because
administrative rules depend on the
statute and and so if it's a statute and
there is no definition elsewhere we need
to Define it somewhere or we need to
specifically state that those
definitions are going to be coming
through the ru making process and that
may have been the intent
but I think that there is a lack of
clarity in the drafting here
that the frustration I'm feeling is I
know that people have put a great deal
of effort into this sure and it's very
clear to me from the emails I'm
receiving that people very much want the
concept but I'm having a really hard
time matching up the words on the page
in front of
me to the specifics of a
concept I hear you representative we
would be very glad to uh help to sort of
better Define the scope of this in a way
that's acceptable to the committee for
certain uh uh again there this this is
intended to Kickstart a process to again
give the department that supported needs
to to develop rules around this and
criteria and standards and so on but uh
in terms of uh sort of better defining
the scope of what we're talking about
we're happy to
do um actually I think maybe I don't
need the followup because we're all
clear that residential treatment is
going to be taken out entirely because
I'm remembering stories about um sober
houses in which the only way you could
address things that were going on there
were through through building codes
rather than through something like this
which is a more appropriate place so
that's entirely outside of the scope of
what we're trying to do here residential
so so Residential Treatment again is not
intended to be included in this bill uh
were it included I'm certain that the
department would not be here speaking as
in as favorably as they have been uh and
certainly um sober housing to the extent
we're talking about is not covered by
this okay so
so if I may have one final um followup
um would
it are you now clear that it would be
very helpful to me if there were
language in here somewhere either
included or reference to where it's
included elsewhere in the statute that
we are talking about clinical outpatient
services which is the overarching
language that's been used a couple of
times here and which doesn't seem to
appear in here anywhere sure and so so
that we have a better definition and I'm
certainly I'm a good drafter but I'm not
Clin I'm
not I don't have the professional
terminology I understand to be able to
dra
for what it is specifically that you're
covering so we would be happy to to to
work with you on that for certain to to
again better Define the scope of what
we're trying to talk about here thank
you okay representative kofalt and then
representative Leon uh thank you just a
point of information so I'm looking at
the Gen Court website and
um if if
residential um if residential treatment
is is a typo it's it's a typo that is
replicated on the Gen Court website in
the as amended by the Senate there's two
versions as amended by the Senate so I
just I I want to clarify that I I you
know my my perception at this point is
that that is in the bill as passed by
the Senate and um that is what we are
working with at this point so I just
wanted to clarify that
yeah representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here to
answer all these questions sure um my
first is it's you're talking about
kickstarting the process for rule making
so is the intention with this that
you're going to figure out what's needed
in the ru making process as far as
identifying the appropriate standard of
care and so and other criteria that that
that um facility that organizations
would be held to I think that that would
be done uh you know be led by the
department done through a process of
stakeholder engagement working with
treatment providers to u to establish
the the needed criteria uh so is then a
followup to that so that would be
working ju for us just to handoff the
entire process to the department and
stakeholders because if we don't put any
guard guard rails on this we have no
input to give in jail car about whether
or not these standards are appropriate I
think that kickstarting the process at
this point would probably be really
getting together and working on this as
an interim studies so we can get the
right language because I'm not
comfortable just handing it off to a
rulemaking where we just said go have
fun with it try and figure it out
especially because we have language in
front of us that says residential
treatment and that's what passed the
Senate but you're telling me that
Residential Treatment isn't part of this
I mean do you do you understand that
this probably isn't ready to move to the
next step at this point I I I understand
I I would I think we can get it in that
shape I think again we that that
certainly I I say typo there's an
unintentional inclusion of residential
and treatment here that's something that
we we I think we can I'm hoping very
easily amend out of the bill as we can
work uh to again better sort of Define
the scope of the uh treatment levels
that we are uh looking to address here
um uh and and I think the you know the
department I think feels like this is a
level of support that they need in order
to Again Begin a process um and and to
be able to fill this Gap and uh and
again ensure best practice all across
our our state um and as more followup um
and and it also was brought up about the
sexual incidents with some of the sober
houses um and that was brought up as
something that's relevant to this bill I
was that a misunderstanding on my part
part because that is residential
treatment and if that residential
treatment and not having accountability
for those Shenanigans is part of the
reason for this then it feels like there
may just be a complete Mis mismatch um
between different people involved about
what the actual scope of the bill is I
think part of what no certainly like
that was in a residential treatment
Network I think what it Expos and help
push a conversation within the provider
community and within the recovery
Community is the again the lack of
oversight that exists uh in certain
parts of the field so certainly that was
you know there was misconduct in that
corner of the treatment Community but
again we've been hearing for years that
this exists elsewhere we again we had
that there you know lots of anecdotes
lots of cases that are known by
providers and by individuals of of this
kind of misconduct and wrongdoing that
um that have existed and uh without um
oversight or correction and as a
followup as that as licensed Residential
Care shouldn't that already be dealt
with within the oversight and if that
oversight didn't do that how does just a
blank check of Ru making in this area
fix the other problems I think that you
know that um I believe the residential
licensing administrative rules are open
for comment now that's something that we
are certainly working on looking to
ensure that these standards that are are
requirements that are in place there are
are appropriate and tight enough to
prevent that kind of thing going forward
um what this is intended to address is
again the lack of over the lack of
oversight that that reporting didn't um
didn't just reveal but reinforced it was
already already known all throughout the
community that that exists again within
the specific segment of the Outpatient
Treatment Network and that exists
despite having licensing of some
segments again these U these outpatient
treatments are not licensed treatment
providers are not licensed they are not
certified there's no level of oversight
in place for that corner of our map so
to speak sorry and I might be a little
dense but the people that made headlines
are licensed those facilities were LIC
and again we are in a parallel way
looking at the licensing regulations to
sure that um they are where they need to
be okay thank you representative P off
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question in your testimony you
were talking about funding provided by
the state and uh about all treatment
providers and then you talk specifically
about best treatment providers so
assuming it has something to do with
efficiency I don't know if you have
number out of your head some percentage
point what is the expected recovery uh
rate uh what is success rate for overall
treatment providers so for the best uh
best treatment providers there I I don't
have it in front of me there certainly
is data available that shows uh you know
the impact and sort of I don't know if
you want to call them success rates but
impact of substances treatment I'm happy
to to follow up and provide that for you
so that would be helpful thank you
any other
questions oh okay thank you all right
thank you
all sure I I think I know what the
question is but go ahead uh the the
question is simply a matter of timing
this this is clearly taking more time
than we had expected and and we have I I
have imposed on several people to become
substitutes and things like that and I
don't know if we're planning to continue
on to an exec session today we're going
to continue all of our executive s than
until next week that's helpful uh this
bill didn't come over to us until Friday
yeah if only it had not come over to us
at all we'd really be in great shape y
but uh it is what it is uh and obviously
we want to fin today but we are going to
continue all of the items on Executive
session until next Wednesday morning and
I know representative shabar you have a
a deadline to get out of here too so
there's several and i' I've informed
representative lonza who's been kind
enough to sit through all of this that
she doesn't need to stay any longer yeah
I mean representative Hobson now I oh
Christina D did you tell representative
Hobson yeah I thought she I saw you
talking so I do have an amendment for
one of the bills we'll be considering
next week I'll pass this out just so
you'll have it on
403 uh but uh at this point let me also
recognize the next speaker on S sp495
Amanda asan from riverband Community me
Mental Health
Center good afternoon is this on yeah
when the lights lit it's on you just
have to be close enough for it to pick
you up as well can you hear me now
yes good afternoon
um well that was a lot of questions so
uh this is only a second time I've done
this so please bear with me um I
provided you with my previous testimony
to uh the senate committee in
January um and I might just go off
script because a lot of your questions
have led me in a different direction
this afternoon um uh my name is Amanda
vashan I the coordinator for the mar
County Drug Court I work for Riverbend
Community Mental Health Center right
over on Pleasant Street in
conquered um I have worked in the drug
court field for over a decade um I
worked primarily in straford
County um and this bill is particularly
relevant to my work um it started in its
original form and I think I want to
speak to that because I think there
might be some confusion regarding the
difference of residential versus
outpatient so my original remarks are
based on the original form of this bill
um which was concerned with the
residential
um
concerns it has been um discussed about
the podcast um The 13th Step and the
sexual um assault allegations that were
part of the largest um Treatment Center
in New Hampshire
when those allegations were brought
forth in that podcast
um as a professional in this community
for many many
years it uh made me lose sleep because
as someone who worked in a mandated
court system and for those of you who
are not familiar with a drug court
system it is a nationally recognized
system that is a
um collaboration between the court
system and the treatment Community to
address um you know someone who is
suffering from substance use who also
has um committed a crime felony level
crime and it doesn't necessarily mean
that their crime was uh you know
committed because they are using
substances at the time but that their
substance use has led them down to a
down a path that has resulted in in
felony level crime and um
to address that the criminal justice
system has decided that substance use
treatment is the best course of action
rather than putting them in prison
because Prison does not make someone
better um what it does is make them a
better Criminal so the drug court
system um is a multidisciplinary team
and so in marrat County we have the
county attorney's office that sits on
the team we have the probation and
parole department we have um the public
defenders office we have conquered
Police Department um we have riverb
Community Health we have um multiple
different agencies that sit around a
table the judge judge Kissinger every
week we sit around the table and we talk
about individuals that are in our
program and we look to find a path
forward for people who are choosing it's
a voluntary program until they plea in
they're choosing that path instead of
going to prison and I will tell you that
that path is harder than going to prison
and you may disagree with that but I am
a professional in this field for more
than a decade and it is easier to sit
behind the walls than it is to address
the things that have happened to
you that got you to this place where
you're committing crimes and you would
rather do drugs than deal with the
trauma that has happened to
you this program
often because of the fact that you have
to deal with your trauma is not e easy
and therefore it sometimes
doesn't
um doesn't follow a straight path you
can get into the program and you're
supposed to be coming to RiverBend on
Pleasant Street and doing outpatient
services and um you know getting
frequently drug tested and going to
probation and parole but sometimes that
level of care is not adequate so our
clinical um uh uh clinical therapist
will send someone to a higher level of
care and sometimes that's in patient
but that also might be PHP level of care
which is included in this form of the
bill that's in front of
you when we mandate someone to go to a
inpatient Center or PHP level of care we
are sending them to a a different agency
that we have no control over and the
reason I say that that podcast and what
it revealed uh you know I lost sleep
over it is because I've sent I've been a
part of decisions that have sent
hundreds of people to those centers and
that means that I have sent potentially
hundreds of people to situations where
they've been
revictimized because they've been
potentially assaulted in those centers
and as it stands right
now there is no mechanism in place for
people to report those types of assaults
you could call the police sure but the
reality of that is not an easy thing
sexual assaults being reported to the
police is not is so under reported
because believing someone
story you just have to watch the news
read a book to know the reality of
that if you're in a system where you are
uh somebody with a criminal
record you've done a lot of things that
you're not proud of and you're at a
point where you're in a treatment center
the likelihood that you're going to be a
believe about something like that is
really
low and then if you complicate that by
somebody in a position of power over you
having done this to you it's even
lower so right now as the system
currently is
designed whether it's outpatient or
inpatient there is no mechanism there's
no
oversight a path that's easy for someone
to confidently report something like
that happening to them
this bill in its current form or in its
previous form allows for the state to
have some
oversight to provide a mechanism for us
to collect the data that um
representative Cobalt is asking for for
us to be able to track how often is this
happening to citizens in New Hampshire
probably more than we'd like it to be
happening this would provide a mechanism
for there to be change made in the state
State this would provide some
legitimacy to treatment across the state
would
provide um a level of care a standard of
care across the state if you could start
wrapping up please um it's important
when we think about how vulnerable this
population is that as a government that
we
provide
um care that we that we care about the
people and that we put some standards in
place um to protect them thank you
representative Weber and then
representative
M so it seems to me that
the
um the number of different terms that
people have
used is sort of representative of the
problem of defining what we're talking
about and uh belie me I am persuaded
that we need some
regulation um and I'm very concerned as
you are about the revictimization of
people already struggling with
trauma past way past current and
otherwise you use the phrase PHP level
of care which doesn't appear anywhere
here and I don't know what the P or the
H or the p stands for and so if PHP
level of care is something we are
talking about could you explain to me
what those words are and how those words
relate to the words that are actually in
the words of the
statute uh the bill as amended by the
Senate sure um I thought I heard the um
DHHS representative say PHP it's partial
hospitalization program okay would that
be okay I've got I've got a partial
hospitalization treatment so that would
be the same thing yes okay great thank
you very much for that clarification I
appreciate it representative McKay thank
you Mr chairman would you believe that I
uh agree with everything you just said
uh but what I would like to see is how
we can translate that into what the
department
does and maybe we could just send uh
Amanda over there and say this is what
we mean because you you've encapsulated
that very
clearly uh as to uh at least from my
point of view uh what we should be doing
and it's that that has concerned me that
I don't see that in the
legislation uh so that how we can
provide that miracle I don't know but
but I'm I'm very pleased with what you
had to say and I think you said it very
clearly so I thank you very much thank
you representative Seth K thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testimony today
really really appreciate it
um I
see I see there being two types of
Institutions um that are labeled here um
there are those that get courta
appointed patients and then there are
those who get patience strictly on a
voluntary basis um
and I guess one of the problems I had
with this is that you know we're it's so
broad that it's going to be including
you know potentially un
unorthodox um uh systems from falling
under by they're going to be forced into
this one siiz fits-all approach and I I
happen to totally agree with you that
you know the certification makes sense
if the if the government is forcing
people to go take care you know take
part in these programs then we want
certification because we want to make
sure that they're their quality long
story short um but there are also people
who are not mandated by the court system
who are going to
voluntarily go get into for example
early intervention programs um
and my concern is that you know um if
they're forced into this certification
program that um they're going to have to
do things by the government book and um
what are your thoughts on
that could I ask you what you mean by
unorthodox well I mean uh there's
there's faith-based um interventions out
there that you know obviously people
that believe in a secular society aren't
going to be in favor of mandating people
go to to or funding um but somebody who
is you know voluntarily taking part in
these programs they might choose to go
to a faith-based program um or or new
age or whatever I mean you use your
imagin imagination so um you know um I
don't know what else to say what are
your thoughts on that um I would say
that um at in our in our regular medical
system that often times so like holistic
medicine for example would be um
traditional insurance right won't pay
for holistic medicine and so people
would can choose to do that but they pay
out of pocket for that and so I would I
would kind of compare those two things
right so people can choose to have
whatever treatment they want to have
sometimes that means paying out of
pocket but if you're going to go if
you're going to get um treatment that an
insurer is going to pay for there's a
set of standards that is required ired
by an insurer to pay for that so if a so
if Medicaid or Medicare or a private
insurer is going to pay for your
treatment there's a set of Standards so
if we're asking um Harvard Pilgrim or
Medicaid to pay for cancer treatment
there's a set of standards for that
cancer treatment so I feel like the
standards for substance use treatment
should be the same across the board if
we're asking insurers to pay for that
treatment so that's what I would
say representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question thank you also
for the work that you do with the drug
courts it's very difficult work but I
think very powerful work as well but I
wanted to talk a little bit um about one
of the comments you made about you know
you're losing sleep because you know
you're mandating people they have to go
to a residential facility and some
terrible things happened there um but we
we heard testimony that hey residential
treatment facilities that's already
covered and in fact explicitly that's
going to be taken out of this so um it
sounds like that's already covered and
yet it's still happened and so I'm just
wondering with what within this
legislation do you think you know having
had a chance to look at it is going to
address the concerns um that that you
have um or is it just should we be
focusing more on just the omus portion
to allow for you know better reporting
of incidences when they occur because
you said it's very hard to when you do
have an issue to come forth with that um
so so I'm just trying to get some
feedback should we be focusing in that
area or what is it about the the front
lure that it doesn't if residential
facilities are already covered it
doesn't look like it's working so I
would just welcome your thoughts
sure I mean I'm going to be completely
honest with you I think that um I
understand why the bill was modified
because I think the dep Department um
did identify that there is a lure
process in place for residential
treatment and so what they've identified
is that this process exists they do need
to make some changes though because the
licensure process exists but the
problems also exist so what they're
basically saying is that there is a
process in place but they're also saying
that that process probably needs to be
modified to better have to have better
oversight to address the issues however
there is no process and oversight in
existence for the outpatient facilities
and providers so this bill separately
addresses a lack of oversight in the
outpatient world that does not exist
whereas the department does have lure
and oversight over residential fac
facilities already so there does need to
be modifications made to an existing
process
already separately um in other words
we're not going to reinvent the wheel
that already exists they have identified
yes this this is already in existence
why not just modify what's already there
to address the concerns and then
separately there's a need to address a
gaping hole here so let's put forth a
modified Bill to address the outpatient
issue
does that
help it does thank you representative
Lon and then representative Merchant um
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for T
taking the questions and thank you for
what you do um I'd actually love to pick
your brain on some other things in the
future too um I I guess the first is the
bill was amended so it doesn't just
cover those that are paid for by
Insurance it actually expands to
everybody so it's changed since then um
I guess drilling down on the issue of
being concerned that you're sending
people to facilities where other people
people have been victims of sexual
assault looking at the statutes on
aggravated fonia sexual assault um it
includes um people in a number of areas
but it doesn't include any include
anybody who um has done this through a
position of Authority or power within a
substance use um program do you think
that enhancing those penalties once
somebody is able to come forward and and
prove and go through that process where
there is a harsher penalty when somebody
who's trusted to help take take care of
them in a substance use facility is the
one who violates them would be one way
to help address this as well I don't
think it's a bad idea to consider that I
think there's a power differential if
you are in a position to care for
someone and you are victimizing them so
similar to if you are um there's a
federal statute there's a u prison rate
elimination act that um ensures
protections for if you are an inmate in
a facility and and
officer um perpetrate perpetrates a
sexual assault against you there's an
inherent power differential there that
in no way can you can an inmate consent
to an officer so I feel like there's a
similar differential there's a
protection if you're a licensed
clinician that you cannot engage in a
romantic relationship or sexual
relationship so I don't see why that
would not be the same if you were in a
facility or an Outpatient Center and You
Were Somehow
um engaging in that um Dynamic no thank
you because it does we do cover a prison
and we do cover the providers but we
don't cover those other people who
aren't licensed and it's unfortunate
that we had to learn it this way but I
think that might be a good correction so
thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking the question and
also uh didto what repres Lon said I
want to say thank you for what you're
doing it's important I'm trying to also
be sure we get this right as much as we
can if the insurance companies and
people paying a treatment center or
paying somebody are they paying the
facility or they paying the
clinician I don't know the answer to
that I think it probably depends on the
structure of where they're receiving
treatment I'm trying to try I'm trying
to sort of separate this out and saying
that if you have a payment methodology
coming from an insurance company coming
from the Department of Health Human
Services whatever it's coming from would
they not themselves have some
requirement for some sort of Standards
before they make the payment I mean I
can't imagine them going into a contract
with an organization or an entity
without having some understanding to
what they're paying
for so the individual uh so the organiz
a would have to have licensed clinicians
to provide a particular
service um so yeah so uh uh for example
Riverbend has licensed clinician to
provide a particular code of service so
if it's individual therapy the clinician
has to have a license in order to bill
for that
service so if I'm Miss hey Mr chair but
they're paying Riverbend for the service
they're not paying the clinician for the
service and what I'm R to be want to be
careful we don't create a situation
where the provider can ultimately behind
behind the
facility I give an example something in
the world of Pharmacy we have the
pharmacy which is owned by corporations
and we have the pharmacist providing the
service and we used to have the person
at the pharmacist would be responsible
on behalf of the corporation so the
corporation would put the pharmacist out
there to Shield themselves and that's my
concern is that all of a sudden we have
a situation where they say I didn't do
anything I don't see the patient that
was the person that did it yet the
culture that we're talking about could
be prevalent within that organization
but they have a sacrificial lamb which
is the clinician because that's the
person we're going to go after so that's
what I'm trying to weave my way through
here and saying I want to be sure that
as Mr Barry said if there's a culture
within that organization we have a way
to identify it and be sure it's not
going to happen once we replace that
clinician and somebody else comes in and
the same power grid you're talking about
is still there and we haven't solved the
problem I think there's a risk of that
for
sure other
questions seeing none okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Michael
Bradley from hopkington
I don't know I'm not sure how much time
you asked about is it
yeah please please cut it down well my
fa
four oh can you push the button your
microphone not make the make yeah hit
the button on the bottom there you go
I'm Mike Bradley I work at the mental
health center of Greater Manchester for
36 years I'm a master licensed alcohol
drug abuse counselor also a licensed
clinical mental health counselor I
thought I should uh add my voice in
favor of this measure uh I think I can
contribute to the consideration although
a lot of points have been covered uh I
fully uh appreciate that the devil is in
the details on this measure as in many
legislative propositions I commend the
committee for probing on various details
to be considered I recognize that this
will be a process of coming up with a
product in the end that does what I
think if I'm reading the room correctly
uh there is a consensus that this kind
of over it would be a good thing uh and
and I add my voice to that General
sensibility uh folks that have ADD asked
for statistics for evidence-based as to
just how widespread the problem is uh
absolutely that those are good questions
my understanding of this measure is it
would help us keep track and have the
answer to that question I can certainly
say anecdotally in my years of practice
yes I have come up uh against situations
where people have experienced uh
substandard care have experienced Frank
abuse of a sexual or emotional nature I
would po I would point out as I think
our previous speaker but I would just
emphasize there are powerful forces
which make it hard for an individual has
experienced that to report it to to
pursue it uh the power differential that
was alluded to certainly and in general
this is a generalization and I own that
folks that are in early recovery uh are
not particularly strong in areas like
self-esteem and self- advocacy uh and so
these make it difficult to follow
through where um such uh such violations
have occurred uh just in terms of
details I I I would say there probably
is some confusion uh in that a lot of uh
places that offer residential are also
offering the uh services that are
mentioned specifically in this bill IOP
which which is intensive outpatient PHP
which is partial hospital so so that
might be I'll cop out I won't say uh you
know how often that happens but that
might be another detail that needs to be
investigated and uh I I also would point
out that yeah where a person's recovery
is sabotaged by substantive care or by
Frank abuse uh the the effects are are
long lasting and pervasive uh and to be
crass they're Financial as well uh
somebody that pursues recovery and is
able to sustain it becomes a productive
citizen pays taxes is is a working
person uh the person that doesn't
succeed in recovery we end up paying we
pay for their imprisonment or we pay for
their
hospitalization uh I don't have the
stats on how many people are weeks at
CMC for endocarditis because they've uh
experienced
uh you know by injecting unclean
syringes uh sure there's a financial
aspect to it so uh in general uh I think
this uh increased oversight is well
worth considering let's see what else I
was scribbling notes as I was listening
but points have been very well raised
but um uh yeah oh I I also um uh yes uh
licensed clinicians like myself uh are
accountable to the to the appropriate
board uh but I think a good percentage
again I don't have the stats a good
percentage of people that are providing
adjunct services or or even qu quazi
Clinical Services uh at some of these
agencies are are unlicensed uh and so so
that would be another uh reason for
advocating further further oversight so
I I'll do my best if you have questions
uh thank you representative
Weber this is a question question that
I'm I'm addressing to you cuz you're in
the hot seat there but uh I'm also
addressing it to the people behind you
do you understand the frustration it is
to sit here and you spoke about the
devil being in the details and that's
what we do yeah this bill do you
understand the problem of this bill
having arrived to our chairman last week
after the Senate it is due out of our
committee next week yeah and I sitting
here do not have the knowledge or the
vocabulary to be able to answer the
questions that have been raised here or
draft the language and I'm I'm the token
attorney on this committee so I'm good
at drafting language but I don't have
the words to draft the language to get
this
bill on its way
within a week and do you understand my
hope that you and others will work very
hard at getting us language that plugs
some of the leaks before next week when
we have to vote we have to vote on this
by next Thursday yeah I I hope my answer
is not a cop out I I trust the
individuals that are advocating this
measure to to work above and beyond what
what should be expected uh to to yes to
uh iron out the the the devil that is in
the details uh but I do appreciate uh
yeah the the uh the urgency the
constraint that you're under with regard
to time it would be great if you could
spend a couple of months considering
this you know exactly and and thank you
for letting
me incorporate my frustration in the
question I appreciate it and and thank
you all for the work you're doing I yes
we do take MasterCard if you wanted to
consolid no that's a joke that's a joke
I'm
sorry representative
Merchant does it come with
points what about Visa AB absolutely yes
just I I want to just
um reinforce what represented Weber said
I think the intent we all sort of can
concur with but the devil's in a details
given the fact that we have 7 days with
a lot of work before
I'm really more inclined to come down to
enim study because I think we need to
have the time to really work it through
and get it right than to try to push
something through I know we folks don't
want to hear that but it's better to
have something that's done
correctly and we can at that point in
time move forward with it versus
something it passes through because
we're on a time crunch and then we try
to figure out how to make it work after
the fact and clean up the mess so that's
where I'm coming down with right now I
know this is not an exact session but I
just want to share with you thank you
for being here and providing it but
maybe the powers the be can work
diligently over the next seven days to
figure out how to make this thing work
um but right now without that kind of
enormous work put into it I'm leaning
more towards U postponing it until the
next year yeah no I appreciate what
you're saying and um uh that's why I
alluded to this as a process I'll leave
it to the wisdom of the committee and
the legislators to figure out how best
to uh articulate and execute that Pro
process representative Lon thank you and
um I'm over this way do you think we
might be able to have a miracle and get
the language we need because otherwise I
also agree that without a miracle from
all the people who are the specialists
in this and that's sort of asking a
question so that I can say something but
do you think we'll get the miracle so we
can actually have language we pass
instead of interim study and a maybe
works I I wouldn't be in this profession
if I didn't believe in miracles and and
I have seen them happen but uh I confess
ignorance as to the legislative process
and that's why I leave it to the
effective advocacy said to work with
you other
questions seeing none hey thank you very
much sir thank you for your
time no one else has signed up for uh s
sp495 FN does anyone else wish to
testify at this
point seeing No One Last Time Christina
can you tell us who signed up on the
blue sheet
I have in favor period great thank you
and representative Lon is looking up
online to see who may have online online
we have 12 in support and one
opposed okay that concludes our business
for today again we have continued our
executive session to next Wednesday
morning at 10:00 a.m. thank you all for
being here and have a good evening we
stand adjourned